we let the rler even was by
baby even and speed hitting the gritty a
grim shaking
fortnite a grim shaking
fortnite a grim shaking fornite
yes oh there's nothing more American
than the Grimace Jake in
[Applause]
fortnite sh
[Music]
forn check out the muscles
on
yo um welcome everybody it's Monday we
had a long break for
Thanksgiving and we are back hope you
guys all had a good long weekend there
with the
family um mine was a total disaster as
you can see in the
title uh which I'll be getting
into uh
shortly
yeah no I know I'm not I'm not looking
forward to talking about it
uhoh not at
all um but how was your guys's
Thanksgiving it was
great all
right what did you did you eat a fake
turkey Dan uh no no no fake turkey I
just uh I ate all the uh the sides you
know and um what's your favorite side
there Dan
[Music]
I don't You're gonna laugh but it's I
don't I don't really have a favorite I
don't really like Thanksgiving
[Laughter]
food you said I'd laugh it's not that
funny I don't
either I actually I I mean I like
Thanksgiving because I like everyone
getting together yes I I agree I don't
dislike Thanksgiving but but like the
the fall Harvest uh food
which makes up the traditional
Thanksgiving meal I'm not about it I
like the desserts I like pumpkin pie and
stuff like that I'm going to agree with
you in that first of all cranberry sauce
on everything is not good like
let's not put cranberry sauce on
everything it's a
weird very strange um I had a big
Thanksgiving Revelation if I may share
what's that please um back on
Turkey oh you like found a turkey you
like yep who cooked it uh my family mom
and brother made it and uh it was
unbelievable and so what was different
this year about the the turkey it was
from a certain Market um Quality Beyond
quality it's a quality bird you got and
it was like the most unbelievably what
was so quality about the bird I don't
know the flavor was on point and um Next
Level outstanding there it is Zach's
back Thanksgiving is back
baby um you know there's also another
thing that needs to be discussed cooking
stuffing inside the turkey is
unhygienic it
is not safe to eat because the stuffing
does not get hot enough to cook out the
salmonella
juices so how many meals have yall been
to where they just slap the stuffing on
your plate out of that Bird's giant
gaping I mean I know it's not
it's gaping but I can't eat out
of a turkey I just like it feels so
invasive in a way that eating the turkey
does not you're desecrating the corps
you're not just eating it you're
desecrating it I got be I'm going to
shove bread up Ethan's ass and then spit
roast him the hardest you like that
little turkey you didn't have to do the
bread that was too much is that real
what you were saying about the salmon
absolutely yeah you you're supposed to
if you do cook it in the bird you're
supposed to take it out and then cook it
again so that it can reach the the uh
safe cooking temperature uh for for
chicken and turkey which I think is
about 180 or something mhm you know this
was my
ass uh so watch out there you know what
I mean and
[Applause]
then
um the pump pumpkin pie literally in the
next day I guess you're supposed to
refrigerate it which I didn't know but
it was covered in mold I want B P we
were sitting there eating that
it was had started to grow mold
colonies after a
day and that kind of goes back to what
we were saying about the pumpkins you
remember how we were like what's with
the pumpkins they're rotting out right
sooner than they should be there's some
kind of weird pumpkin conspiracy
happening and it's a ruining
Thanksgiving and
Halloween I will say the Thanksgiving
Spirit was in full effect do that have
any impact on the Halloween spirit I
don't know I felt those are intertwined
uh holidays you know what I mean I I I
felt there was more spirit for
Thanksgiving than there was for
Halloween tell me about that I don't
know there were Good
Vibes family just in the in the
Bernstein household yeah everyone you
know no a mer just lot no drama everyone
was enjoying a Mery gay oldy Mery and it
was Mery and your merthy Gale
Thanksgiving uhhuh was there alcohol did
you guys drink no it was a dry it was a
dry uh a dry gay Miry experience some
dry
turkey um I'm also nobody at my house
ever drinks and we brought we had all
kinds of guests we we actually had a
pretty big Thanksgiving I think the
biggest ever
does anyone drink does is there drinking
involved yeah yeah your family gets you
you guys all drink yeah we get sosed
really Dan I'm exaggerating but do your
parents get a little tipsy on
Thanksgiving a little bit
sure drink like wine and stuff we're not
like hitting the sauce yeah sounds fun
though too much wine sorry nobody I just
I don't know nobody wants to drink ever
in my house ever older I get I find
booze gives me like a hardcore headache
yeah I agree I just I don't the the
return uh investment is not there on the
drinking it just makes you so
tired
too right Zach right I'm an old man dude
I feel like you have to be somewhat of
an alcoholic to enjoy alcohol because
like you have to drink it that's not
true it is and I'll tell you I like
drinking but I I rarely drink I'll tell
you enjoy it why it's because you have
to drink so frequent
that your body gets accustomed to you
know some of the worst effects of it
like being hung over or getting
headaches or getting sleepy cuz like my
whenever I would drink with friends in
college it was the ones that were
drinking every day that seemed like they
were having the best time because they
you know what I mean
they they can drink and drink and drink
and they don't get sick and they're just
having so much fun and
the biggest drink of I'll have a few
drinks and I'm like I'm I'm done dude I
think I'll puke if I keep drinking
more so shout out to the alcoholics it
is the biggest drinking out of the
deal shout out I mean the same with
smoking cigarettes like when you first
start smoking cigarettes it's horrible
it's the worst thing ever but then you
know after like maybe a couple weeks or
maybe even one week or a couple days I
don't know after a couple days you
become cool right yeah and so this is
the same with alcohol I think you need
to drink every day for like a week and
then you're then you're in you just have
to prime your body that's the guy I had
sex with who smoked cracket with me oh
yeah I know that guy he's a good
dude um he's a really good
dude uh anything else any other
Thanksgiving uh mirth that anyone wants
to share any Miry times any girthy times
well we have a little uh a game that
we're going to play later but maybe we
could just do it now um involing our
Thanksgiving experiences that's true we
have a little fun game was this an idea
from the
audience I think it may have maybe was
something on the subreddit I wanted to
give a shout out but um well whatever
you're out there if you know who you
are everybody took a photo of their
Thanksgiving
[Applause]
table uh
anonymously and I your host Ethan
Klein will try to determine whose
table is whose
table right right yeah that makes sense
right that's right so that'll be fun
that's exciting I think there's lots to
talk about there yeah so let's just do
that first I think you're right you know
okay I'm opening up to you umic right
now one thing I do want to say at the
top here is thank you to our members we
love you guys so much we don't have
sponsors ever anymore for some reason
yeah and so you guys are yall make the
world go around here at the H podcast
and we love the sponsors thank you guys
the memberships I
mean uh we also love uh to shout out
Teddy fresh which is my wife's company
you guys may or may not know I have
nothing to do your wife my wife my wife
my
wife up to 60% off guys it's going
through till Thursday also the magic the
Gathering release is popping right now I
for example am wearing um this hoodie
which I love let me show you guys the
graphic it's a full embroidered plate I
love the embroidered plates so cool
right sick thanks yeah thanks man yeah I
agree it's like a it's really just a
beautiful artistic yeah that color too
that might that's hoodie specifically
might be my new favorite hell yeah yeah
it's comfy too I like that fit yeah so
um this is what I'm wearing AB you got
one on too right I not from the magic Dr
oh yeah this is from the the recent quit
disrespecting my mother talk nice talk
nice huh earth clean and do what even
soon I haven't heard thought about that
in a while nice huh
speak to me
nicely yeah check that out and a lot of
other stuff but we love moms yes we do
and we love love yes we do talk to me
nice Ethan talk to me nice he's in love
also this a final week for trading
cards 100% goes to the
crew support them and get yourself some
really
cool
Collectibles it's up for one more week
yep the red are sold out so just the
greens green ones right now the green
ones are available you can still get
Ethan's credit card there's uh we split
them so 500 for the red ones and 500 for
the green ones I saw a few people in the
subreddit they pulled it and I was like
you know Christmas come early some yeah
and as of now we've sold less of the
green ones so there's technically a
higher chance to get a credit card if
you buy the green ones I'm say you know
there tip for you guys here yep math
okay is anyone actually going to go try
to swipe that at like Trader jails or
something you should try it cuz it's
real didn't we tell you that'd be
awesome we put your real digits on there
yeah know I know yeah yeah we've
literally had to clarify to customers I
guess or Max the trading guy guy he's
been having to like reply to people no
that's not actually a credit card they
want to use it people want to use it SE
yeah I've seen comments like that is is
there money on the credit card yeah go
use it try it out might I mean if you
look at that and and you genuin like
this is a this is real money yeah then
then you deserve to go you are an H3
podcast fan you're our favorites and
thank you for your support by the way
love you thank you that's a fan that
spent money on merch so we love you yeah
go to Trader Joe's and get yourself
something nice on me go to Joe's go to
Joe Joe uh what else we got um go to Joe
uh this is
ready who's gobbling that you know what
some thing is killing me like I I don't
know what happened if like I had a gum R
eating or if I got a chip but there's
like a really
sharp what happen Ridge oh and my tongue
keeps catching on it I have that to
painful and annoying m i get that too
every now and then on my right tooth in
here but it goes away what do you me
yeah it goes away after like a two a
couple weeks huh mhm how I think it
depends on how hard you brush and how
much you annoy the the the skin or
whatever you think it's a gum receding
thing no it's not permanent it's should
happens when I it up a little bit
every dude it's so annoying like
I can't talk I can't do anything and
then I keep tonging it because I'm
uh a freak I think we all do
that though you know you can't stop
tonging it my tongue is raw it's like
hurts help it's on the tongue or is it
no it's in it's right on the bottom my
front tooth so when I talk my tongue
rubs against it you sure there not
something stuck in there no it's no you
can feel that piece of a shell or
something it's a divot it's like there's
a you can feel it it's a
Kass yeah yeah know I got you it's a
creal I don't know if I can shave it
down I I don't want to go to the
dentist it's not like a part of your
teeth I think it's just like in s we
call a tooth Rock but definitely not
called it that oh you're saying you have
plaque plaque it's plaque I don't think
it's plaque I think it's plaque that
that is shaped yeah look yeah you want
me to look dig around in there all right
yeah I got light you're going here
someone come you going to get a camera
okay good you so that they can see
AB so yeah grab the camera so the
audience can I'm sure there's at least
10 dentists in the chat that can
diagnose me and then there's also a few
oncologists who can diagnose my mouth
cancer which it probably is related to
so you want the reason I know that is
cuz I've had that isent times and I've
asked my dentist about it
like so I is this line up with you so
it's this tooth here the little one in
the front yes on the very bottom in the
back I have a little bit of up
tooth you see that on behind I get that
on that one all the time yeah hold it
hold it Wiener that's what I who I need
to ask man like it's starting to come
through okay all right so we're going to
we're bringing the camera out so you
guys can diagnose
me love you got to come look at this
well I'll see see it on the screen right
yeah I'll take it close look go ahead so
it's it's hard to point out you'll see
there's like a receding gum it's not
that one it's the one next to it
Spotlight mode here right
here right down okay yeah yeah that
looks like a piece of plaque my guy no
you can see that really I think so I
think so it's wider right well then get
get me a pick I'll pick it right now
okay I'll get you a pick okay a hard
metal one no get me cuz I've try I don't
think it's Flag I think it's I think
it's tooth I hope you're right though H
let me
look let's see what the doctors in the
uh in the chat I can't go on
I'm a dental student I got you Ethan all
right let's see what the dental student
has to say I don't think you're supposed
to hard enough what you're not supposed
to scrape your own teeth it's you can
scrape off yeah there's not you're not
supposed to do a lot of things all right
go for it then but this isn't sharp
enough I need like a metal
one we have metal
ones we have toothpicks but um Sam can
you order a um a hard metal is Sam here
I'm here yeah can you order a a like a
instacart instacart me some like a
dental scraper a dental scraper
that like the hygienist use I have one
at home I love that thing oh you have
the metal one yeah oh yeah I'm probably
not supposed to be doing that at home
myself
but I don't know I like how it feels I
want I'm going to bring it home and I'm
going to my whole mouth up fold it
all right cool okay I need that that now
cuz dude I'm telling you this will give
me so much relief this is the most
annoying thing tooth Loop is some are
saying yeah the diagnosis from the chat
is in are you ready for what you have we
have um hold on hold on you have mouth
lice you have a creas you have Lupus
tooth
lupus uh a
cavity uh tartar tartar a cavity oh what
are they EMB based in cavity lupus what
does a cavity feel like uh feels like
say you've never had one right it
doesn't hurt at all depends how severe
it is you cannot feel it at all to
excruciating pain so yeah I mean I've
never really had a
cavity so I just I I reject the very
notion of it it's absurd or as Jordan
Peterson would say it's absurd absurd
absurd
huh uh more
I'm so excited I'm do you guys want
anything else while postmating I don't
know it feels funny just to postmate one
dental pick but cheit cheit okay let's
get some cheit anything else pick and
pick what was that panko pick and pick
and chicken what what oh I wanted
to say Bella Simmons welcome back nice
to see you thank you for the 50 gifted
we love you man we love Bella Simmons I
hope you specifically had a fantastic
Thanksgiving thank you me too that's so
nice it's a gift for
everybody oh God I'm so people are
saying it's Cal calculus wait is that a
joke calculus like I know you're saying
calcium thing but what it's somebody
says you have egg tooth egg tooth heart
tooth
calculus those
eggshells are you falling for that no it
looks like a thing it is a thing oh it
is a thing yeah like a calcium that's
what it's referring to
oh like here let's see careful showing
that yeah okay so it's not I know what
you mean this is like plaque buildup I
don't I don't think it's that no it
didn't look that far
down
ah I hope that's what it is I don't
think so man that's crazy that you never
had a
cavity yeah I think I don't know I mean
I am a pretty obsessive brusher but at
the same time
I don't know if I just have like super
good genetics wait I'm looking at at
Tarter and this looked more like what
you had so I translated what I thought
it was what my dentist said it was and
it's tartter okay yeah so that cified
deposit that forms on the teeth tooth
tartar like tartar sauce like tartar
sauce yes tooth
tartar all right well let's see I mean
those are really severe cases of it but
it looked like bit of that yeah little
bit of that nice little candy corns for
you huh
Olivia snack on one of those that's
nasty that is nasty yeah please brush
your teeth my dad also has um I think
only one cavity so I don't know if it's
like a genetic thing
smash but then my mom has a bunch of
cavities so I don't know I had four or
five before I was at elementary school
really yeah what what was your brushing
habits like I I was always uh keeping up
with brushing I just my grandma gave me
a lot of candy I had like a candy drawer
and like I basically grew up at her
house and I was just nonstop eating
candy and drinking pop so that'll isn't
that all kids though to an
extent drinking soda nonstop I mean soda
and candy all the time and you got to be
technically you're supposed to like
brush after every time you eat but not
too fast after you eat apparently cuz
then you your teeth up cuz they're
weak after you eat and then you scrub it
and it ruins them H you know your teeth
are weak after you eat after you eat
like sugar usually at least and you
brush immediately after you harm the
teeth that cannot be true that is 1,00%
cannot be true Google it you're not
supposed to brush don't brush after you
eat sweets not directly after no oh my
God there's no way that's true it's true
my sweet is DST has told me I don't know
what's going on in Sweden cuz love was
trying to convince me that snoo is
doesn't cause mouth can also I did not
try to convince you I said there studies
okay I am seeing uh there was a result I
don't know how credible this is but it's
top result says before read before you
read it what's the URL Golden State
Dentistry that's good that's a good
website so I have no
idea go
ahead but it says brushing too soon
after you finish eating sugary or acidic
food can damage the enamel R hold on let
me let me ask chat ask GPT so you want
some teeth you want some
teeth that website and Shad is saying
I'm right so I got to be chat is saying
don't brush after you eat sweets Chad is
Right Chad always knows that makes no
sense what dentist would say don't brush
after you eat sweets it just says too
soon it sounds like when the you when
it's in your mouth yeah yeah same CU
it's acidic and if you're brushing your
teeth the teeth the Nal could be
weakened so wait we have a dentist on
speed dial you want me to T let's get
him yeah no we don't I'll text him text
him this Zach is actually putting
forward Jimmy Lee to contact you're so
full Zach I think you love him
love him dude text him you want
text him Zach cannot ever stop
complaining about Jimmy and now and yet
I think you love Jimmy of course I love
the guy there you go
but I have a LoveHate relationship with
him I do want to ask him though that is
I kind of want to pick his brain on that
like legitimate Dental questions only
you want him to call in yeah just Dental
questions D we'll keep it short we'll
keep it short we'll keep it sweet send
me that
Zoom he's been Jimmy's been having a
rough time he's getting creamed out
there yeah after that last interview we
had with Alex the documentary guy where
he exposed himself Alex was getting kind
of cream
too um yeah it was a loose loose
situation it was yeah it was just a lose
lose Mike Clum came out looking good oh
yeah for sure was M Clean yeah uh Moz
boss came out uh looking the same as he
started it's mozzarella time he the I
want that Moz boss in this studio man I
want that I want that you know what I
think as much as I love mods spos and I
know y'all are super mad at Jimmy right
now and people are over him I have I
have a soft spot for for Jimmy Lee I I
feel bringing Mo boss on would be a
betrayal I'm with
you and like I just don't want to do
that to the guy because at the end of
the day there is a certain kinship
between us you know Jimmy he's our
histrionic son of a
gun you know yeah mbos can be someone
else's history onic son of a
gun
he said he can call in in an hour an
hour tell him to stop doing whatever
he's doing tell his patient to wait yeah
it's not
funny he's like doing actual dental work
on somebody drops everything he's doing
to call in dude he for sure is drilling
someone's teeth and then looked at his
phone hoping it was Zach oh without a
doubt dude he says
impossible impossible impossible about
what to call in right now ask what is
doing oh yeah he I mean he's probably
working on someone's teeth holding his
phone in one hand and the drill in the
other all right so is it a pass then
yeah okay well he okay he says he's
sorry no it's okay just tell him I'll
never it's not okay I'll hold it against
him forever a grown ass man with like a
whole Dental Empire can't get on the
phone with me at the drop of a hat at
any given time in any given day I mean
he usually does you're right he does not
today
not today people saying Jimmy's racist
but like yeah okay again it's told timey
racism again it's
like
yes but it's Jimmy Lee shoot the son of
a that doesn't mean anything to me
because it's
like he's got he's
histrionic yeah okay you know
I you know he's our
guy
kabish all right thank you so as I wait
for my dental pick cuz I am actually
losing my mind here tonging my
tooth let's go ahead and play our uh
Thanksgiving who's Thanksgiving dinner
who's gobbling that down welcome
everybody and happy post Thanksgiving
today I will be judging each
Thanksgiving dinner table and trying to
guess who dinner table was this H quite
the spread here so let's go ahead and
get started shall we
okay who's gobbling it
down here's the album so I'll just go
one one at a time
here all right first
up
interesting let's take a look so
okay it's what what's here what is this
fish
is that
salmon I guess you no but you can't
answer but there's no sides it's just
salmon and
turkey what is this the Joe Rogan
Thanksgiving so clearly a nice crafty
situation they got the little turkey
napkin holders that's someone who's
festive that's someone who's getting
into the holiday
cheer the bird is cut quite
interestingly as well oh they're G those
aren't turkeys those are game
hens those are four little uh game hens
I believe fried chicken cut
right down the
middle
h
Huh
huh
well uh ab and Lena what did you guys do
for Thanksgiving did you guys have a
traditional meal wait can you ask that
well did well well well you'll see
you'll see not very fair you'll see
other pictures in that are very
non-traditional so that will definitely
give you a big advantage on those is
this a bottle of wine here looks like
uhhuh so that's that's for some reason
I'm
thinking it's not Dan it's not
Zach
Ian I don't know anything about Ian's
family good people if they were the type
to bring a turkey napkin
holder Sam would have a a crazier spread
than this she would have more
sides you
know so I'm going to say Olivia for no
particular reason other than
Because by the process of
elimination
okay yeah and who prepared your
Thanksgiving uh table or dinner um Whole
Foods my mom my sister and me oh it was
a Whole Foods collaboration yeah add our
little that could be a Whole Foods
Chicken
right could be also there's a bottle of
wine you mentioned that there's some
drinking happening I did Dan's family I
feel like there's just too much meat
here they're they're a bunch of hippies
I get the
feeling am I right about that Dan uh not
really I mean they are a bunch of
hippies but I'm the only vegetarian in
the
family yeah all right so let's go ahead
I'm going to put this on
Olivia okay we'll see it's tough
call I love these little
hand things that you made here your
sister and your mom who prepared it yeah
okay okay that's a lot of people
involved for Just Fish and CHS mhm all
right well let's move on uh I've given
my best my best
attempt okay now this is a different one
this is a bucket of KFC
chicken Fried
Chicken cam what what were you doing on
Thanksgiving um I actually didn't
participate in this uh spread because I
didn't have a good Thanksgiving a what
happened I I'm not at Liberty to talk
about it right now but oh yeah but I
just didn't participate so sorry I meant
to I was typing out a message earlier
but forgot I I'll tell you he he tried
to eat and we taught him listen listen
he said your ass down he wanted someone
to feed him and nobody would feed him
I'm sorry about that cam that's
okay you
know you should we do a Thanksgiving for
Cameron should we order Thanksgiving
food no it's okay
oo I'm a little Thanksgiving doubt yeah
me too I would definitely rather get so
who got KFC I mean that's definitely a
love thing
who would eat KFC for Thanksgiving love
wood and then ab and Lena did you guys
go I mean did you guys go back home
essentially is what I'm asking no we
didn't
okay and did you guys was it just the
two of you mhm mhm so I feel like this
could be you guys could do this too
there a love what Lena oh just a bucket
of chicken us I feel like I don't know
you worked you the maniac that was
eating the the Carl's junr breakfast or
some yeah that was egg and cheese
yeah so I mean it's definitely something
we would do yeah no no I'm just curious
no I think so
mhm um it's not Zach it's not Dan Olivia
Ian not Ian obviously it's got to
be I think it's going to be love though
I mean who else would and if this is a
meal for one you know what I
mean
uh which is quite sad when you think
about it first I should I'll I should
invite you to
my you did
no so we doing love I'm going to put
that on love for sure I'mma put that on
love felt that I mean and as far as
Thanksgiving meals Go I mean you
can't go wrong with a bucket of chicken
man that is crack that's a good
chicken how do they get the flavor all
in the meat that's what I don't
understand I don't know it goes
penetrates deep you're right like you
can you can take all the meat off the
bone yeah you can rinse it with water
cuz sometimes I do that for for the dogs
and then you taste it and it's still
salty like do they brine it I don't know
they deep fry that hard I think
it tastes like jerky just I I wonder if
they stick holes in or something they
must brine it yeah probably that's the
only way but which that's the way to do
it though yeah
um this is just a black picture that was
Cameron's I
think that is that meant to be a photo
or is it it's just to divide it so you
can't see the next you're scrolling look
how thoughtful he was wow wow very nice
really oh my God look at that spread
holy smokes
hm wait I know who this is
H this is my thing this is what we had
at Thanksgiving did Ela send you
this uh yes she did
okay we had a ton of people come and
everybody was cooking this was like
Israeli salad that um Ela made my sister
made turkey and
stuffing uh ela's mom made rice and this
wonderful bean stew with meat sweet
potatoes and um marshm mows green beans
and what are these little
things what are those little turds turds
bunch of what's this is that a
potato yeah it looks like maybe they
nice plate of food
though are those your potatoes is that
the ones we've been hearing about I
don't hold on don't let's just
focus yeah I have I do want to talk
about the potato travesty that being
said I am still
ready on Wednesday for the potato off
which we are doing
right I think I'm gonna have to go with
the mashed potatoes
though because a roast how am I even
going to do that here because you have
to you kind of have to eat it right out
of the
oven cuz if I transport it here from the
house it's going to get all soggy well
everyone will transport it here so it's
just about which one's
best
interesting right I don't know though
that's tough I mean potatoes are well
know
like the drop off a fussy in likeability
is pretty rapid we've talked about with
the fries which fries are like from
which place last you know the thing is
mashed potatoes warm up quite well true
so I'm feeling confident in that but
other Potato um mechanisms I'm not
confident
in anyway okay well that's nice I I
compliment my own I said hey look at
that
spread that was at my
spread you
know um all right let's take a look here
this is
interesting okay we have
beef
brisket that looks like tri tip or
brisket we got a nice looking turkey
gravy oh the the potato Med
Medan what do you call that
dish I love it uh like a and potatoes oh
yeah potato
a
arra arra
br what the is this is that
stuffing that must be stuffing mhm
mashed potatoes sweet
potatoes that's a complete that's a good
whome thing right there let me think
about
this
h
these potatoes don't look like they were
cooked in this cuz there's just the
plate isn't
dirty and there's just not enough to
fill it which makes me think maybe it
was
store-bought and warmed up in this plate
oh detective over here which makes me
think if I think about Olivia said that
she had a collaboration with Whole
[Music]
Foods um but that being said this is
this all looks
homemade the yams the mash the
stuffing and this looks homemade too I
mean this meat I don't think you can buy
meat like that you'd have to cook
that Zach did you have meat at your
Thanksgiving know your way around some
meat pleading the fifth your
honor I'm going to say Zach only because
of the presence of the of the meat
although again is Zach said he's back on
the
turkey well looks like they have both
right after last year though your
grandma better bring out the steak your
way around some meat I'mma put this one
on Zachary zacharo damn you said my full
name it gave me fear Zachary sorry dude
Zachary gave you a panic attack yeah do
your parents call you Zachary ever just
when they're like uh piss yeah yeah the
full
name H God damn
it what are you what are you doing in
there nothing
good all right Zach that one's on you
buddy ooh I like the colors wow oh my
goodness okay I know who this is that's
got to be Sam's I mean look at the
cornbread with the dollop oh and I of
course the the cornbread
sule I believe that's what that is or
this might be a roll but everything here
is just deliciously plated also it's on
paper plates though that's
interesting I think Sam and Ian would go
paper plates it's easy to clean up like
an aunt if you're at like a family's
house or an aunt's house or some
they're going to bring out the
China but Sam and Ian I could see them
doing the paper plates and no and by all
means you know what I mean the LA the
worst part about Thanksgiving is the
cleaning
up this is has to be Sam's and might I
say this that is a lovely beautiful
plate of food there
Samantha Miss
Temple I want that
actually I want that want that in terms
of Thanksgiving D like plates this is a
really nice one because it doesn't have
cranberry
sauce W you
what is this thing here though what is
this stuffing maybe oh stuffing yeah
that's got to be
Sam very well done
Sam okay what is
this so what's in the box or Earth Cafe
is this literally just
coffee no Earth Cafe has all kinds of
stuff okay okay okay okay cuzz I don't
know what Earth Cafe is so they they
make food there yeah
yeah is there any association between
Earth and Whole
Foods uh no overpriced yeah same crowd
I've never heard of Earth Cafe so good
it it is really top tier am Earth Cafe
is pretty good they uh their pumpkin pie
is greatest thing ever bomb pies do they
deliver I think they're on the delivery
app yeah probably they're on like
Postmates I I want to check out Earth
but you know how much that
pumpkin Pi is
$100 what wait for a pumpkin pie are you
I don't believe you send me a link I got
to see that I mean Earth Cafe price but
that's crazy I mean is it like a
monsterized
pie is Zach seriously I remember getting
them and they were 100 bucks come on bro
that's crazy you got to find me the
price there's no way they can't be right
no way it can't be if it's $100 I will
in my pants right now I remember
they line they line up for this is not
mine but they line up for them one slice
with whipped cream is
875 I remember but then a whole buy is
not going to be a hundred I remember
them being $100 at one point I I used to
go with my dad lined up for them at
Earth Cafe $100 Chris $100 bill was a
$99 how old were you at the
time 10 years
ago years ago with inflation it's like a
$200 pie now so you were like 14 that I
mean that's young enough for your dad to
with you I feel like he still
with me
yeah 14 is young enough to for your dad
to convince you he spent $100 on a pie
if it's $8 for a slice how many slices
is there in a pie eight oh maybe they're
bringing the that's what I'm saying and
it's not it's more expensive per slice
right you buy the whole pie it's going
to be cheaper so still going to be
expensive but you guys can't find the
price online I'm trying to find it on
their website but it's kind of it's
kind of shitty so this is a Swanky
Affair clearly this is a upscale uh meal
what the is in this oh it be it
would probably be a pie the pie yeah
probably I'm seeing on this website that
it's $4 I'm seeing
$50 don't get me wrong that that is
expensive that is 55 for a pumpkin pie
that's still an expensive misremember
the memory maybe it was a $50 bill and
and Grant versus Franklin you know they
look so yeah yeah that's a very
expensive pie nonetheless I just I I
remember being a hunter and now that
you've learned it's 40 maybe we got two
of them it was 55 55 to be fair oh maybe
you got two of them that would make
sense yeah with tax and stuff who would
be 100 bucks as side note every time I
go to Earth Cafe I see a fan for some
reason every single time last time me
and Cameron when we saw a fan oh we
shouldn't saw a few is this a is this a
chain yeah there's one downtown but the
one that is it La chain no no we went to
the one in Orange County in Orange not
too long ago too this area though I've
never I had one in Vegas not too long
ago oh in Vegas okay okay yo do their
Lattes or cappuccinos really look like
that they do the stupid this is yeah the
most like up your own ass wait they do
this I mean that's pretty impressive
baring they do the whole thing they have
professional Baristas yeah oh my God
yeah it's very like snoody very snoody
place um let's get the menu open is it
yeah it's the if you're drawing pictures
in the foam you're up your on period I
mean and that's not just like a
little something that's like serious
that takes that takes skill
practice training that's the downtown
one all right it looks nice it's nice
it's nice and the food is definitely
good but it's it's overpriced and it's
always really crowded and really
kind of e what is that what are these
little T toasted turds on this little
bacon to little bacon bag of
turret what I'm sorry but who wants a
full piece of bacon just I mean don't
you want to cut it up though I don't you
want it in pieces yeah you want want to
spread out
yeah that's just silly
Earth Okay so we've got the Earth pies
so this is a cultured uh ordeal we got
the sweet potatoes light on the
marshmallows my goodness that was a
stingy stingy marshmallow
spreader he that's actually it looks
like my pumpkin pie when it had mold on
it
frankly but this is all homecooked
definitely broccoli and
Sprouts the turkey has definitely been
carved up and
demolished rest in peace big eaters big
old pan of gravy love that
stuffing what's the deal with this is
that I think that's a cooking pan mashed
potatoes all right let me think here
Earth there's wine
too a really nice uh stove top too too
much wi true that's true good good good
noticing nice stove
top and then in this this
says vegan wait that says vegan vs Vegan
vegan barers bakery barber shop barber
shop too vows they're vegan hold on I'm
going to do some Ops on this oh we're
doing Ops we got Ops vals
vegan vegan I think it says bake shop
okay I found
it uhuh so this is one spot there is
this just one I think this just one
location oh well you can't really use
this without like pseudo doxing one of
us so uh oh I think it's well hold
on like let me see $28 no matter how you
spend this is a lot for some
cookies still expensive but then you
also have to factor in that the bags
aren't even big to begin with it's 4 o
per bag 4 oz of cookies for $7 is still
a lot especially when you Charlie you
should hear about the pies man you think
approved those were $10 a bag for 14 o
they more of product and they were sold
in Costco a lot enoyed them you're
trapped at a party talking to
somebody $ for a bag of cookies
is for a smaller bag of cookies
significantly smaller is a lot too
significantly smaller it doesn't matter
how you boil down this map all roads
lead to this being in expensive product
that's the brass tax of it that is the
hard pill to swallow a hard swallow no
way of spinning this where $28 for a
four pack of these cookies isn't
expensive it
is people broke for not buying it or not
being able to afford it is really some
out of touch and the Really foul
part about all this that my little
noodle will never be able to wrap
itself bu you need them and you are stop
talking in their mouth right
now by just insulting them right uh
that's really about
it all right man I get it they're
expensive dude it's just whatever dude
you should go to Earth Cafe I'm telling
you all right so I'm kind of stumped on
this I mean I'm not I have a lot of
leads have a lot of leads it could be I
have the location though that's the real
kind of part that's throwing me although
I mean it's La anyone could come
here
vegan
though cam oh wait Cam's not
participating Dan keep in mind it's the
whole family too it doesn't necessar if
there's a vegan option doesn't that's
true on anybody in this room necessar
that's true but I do
know can I ask Sam and Ian are your guys
separate or together ours are together
okay they vegan golly who the is
this goly am I forgetting some you love
go lately go Zach I did Dan I haven't
done Olivia I did you have not done me
yet or it's basically just me and am and
Lena unless yeah there's only one after
this so so this has got to be
Dan this has got to be Dan fam and
there's a bottle of wine as
well although ah that doesn't make sense
because your family doesn't even live in
LA
right my family yeah well they don't
live in LA but they live
nearby I saw my family on Thanksgiving
okay hold on let me type to you cuz I
don't want to say anything too revealing
but I do want to
confirm this may even be P something
you've already
said oh okay this is Dan this is Dan
that lines up okay that lines up with
everything that's
Dan thank you so that just leaves one
more with ab and
Lena oh I did it this is totally ab
and
Lena's there's no way this isn't a and
Lena there's two plates
steaks where the what is this
meal one looks like
corn and mac and cheese is that mac and
cheese but like with shells shells but
so did you guys order these sides
separately and then the stakes you made
or did you order the stakes like
something well we should let's do the
reveal and then all of your answers can
all right this is AB and Lena I'm
actually feeling somewhat confident here
in my choices I got to say yeah overall
I think you did well I I only know my
own so I only know whether or not you
got me um I was guessing along with you
on all the rest so so uh well let's
start from the top shall we all right so
top left let me go to the top here
so in the count of the fish and turkey
spread game hens
actually I said
Olivia Olivia was this your meal this
was not my meal
no that was that was one of the ones I
was more unsure about this one's hard I
mean there's nothing good work there's
nothing happening here no sides
so it's mine that's yours and I feel bad
because it is is a little deceptive
because when I took the picture right as
we were sitting down and all of the uh
sides were not they they were set on a
table next to the table and I was
instructed to just do the spread so you
could have taken two photos it is the
fact that it's all meat in this photo
and it's mine was very deceptive but I I
swear that was not intentional so were
these game hens and they were you
correctly identified that yeah nobody in
our family likes turkeys so they just
they just do other and that was and
that those are delicious salmon in the
background as well so I okay so I
identified the food and there were all
the sides were like the traditional
Thanksgiving sides but uh but no
turkey oh man all right now I'm
all now I'm all tangled up combobulated
I think the
rest okay I I won't comment but I I
think you're uh I think you're still in
good shape so loves KFC uh KFC bucketed
Chicken on Thanksgiving love was this
year's yeah it was and was it good it
was lovely so good right so delicious
mhm what do you get from KFC's other
than the the bucket you get any sides
yeah I got the like bucket with two
sides and I got like mac and cheese and
which side you get mac and cheese and
potato nice where mashed potato gravy
actually like their COA never had it I
don't like COA so that's not for me it's
a nice it's it's nice because it's like
I think it is somewhat healthy I mean
it's just tons of like really Earth
something love would eat right yeah but
it's very tasty you should try it I mean
it's pickled and I think you'd like it
col yeah no I don't like col you like
cabbage no I love cabbage all it is is
like cabbage yeah I don't I've never
really liked cabbage or Co cabbage by
itself is kind of like a weird one but
when it's prepared right cabbage is one
of the
greatest vegetables crunch crunchy crisp
absorbs so much flavor true you got a
good point cabbage on its own is like
like a very low tier vegetable by the
way people are saying I spent uh spent a
lot I've been with friends and also the
crew had a little thing this uh weekend
so so thank you for saying that I didn't
want it to make it seem cold blooded I
know love did have Thanksgiving plan yes
I'm just I misspoke I know he did I had
a very good time yeah cabbage is
actually very nutritious it's very
nutritious klaw how am I supposed to say
it someone said the way Ethan says klaw
klaw that's crazy it's klaw yeah yeah
yeah I mean that's how it's spelled
[Music]
it's oh by the way I didn't even say um
the laugh you lose 2023 is up we put
that up on uh Saturday Friday but yes
Friday it's a video and it's up now for
anyone that wants to watch it it was
fun good time it was fun mhm I rewatched
it this weekend and you did yeah
tradition and actually was able to laugh
at the videos actually I laughed a lot
on the thing yeah yeah I got pretty I
got pretty I'm I'm I'm sitting
with Ian next year I'm hiding in the
back there's no winning next year dude I
feel like we have to step up the
punishments we need to get like Step Up
the punishments hold on okay I don't
want to necessarily go down this road
right now but you should not be the one
deciding because you you bitched out on
the punishment do we want to talk about
that now maybe we have to talk about it
now no you got called out majorly dude
well you don't want to let's finish our
segment at Le okay that's I I realized
as I was starting but I was just so
upset by listen I will take it on listen
I will take this on I'm not dodging
it but let's just at least stay focused
here uh can we get Earth's Cafe though
for real you want it uh we could order
from there like to try it are they on
posties they are on posties let me see
that they a boba you know Earth has boba
they do have good Boba they really
do that people are saying kosla Ethan is
right so coasta to my coasta
um uh friends in chat I see
you all right so I got you
[Applause]
[Music]
love this is me right so you got that
one correct yeah very good would have
been funny if you
didn't yeah it would have been huh but
no I know it I knew it this one I said
was Zach you said Zach I'm not super
confident about it I'm not sure I feel
like Zach's family would would have the
Earth Cafe
but they they live far away from
the Earth
Cafe uh my dad will drive anywhere for
food just putting that online all right
well let's just tell us Zach who uh is
this yours that is mine yes oh so you
did get it right it was the meat the
meat gave it away yeah my dad um barbecu
tri tip special for me so it was nice
that's oh yeah that looks delicious it
was an exceptional meal my so he went
out of his way to make you the steak but
then you ended up eating the turkey and
liking it well I I ate the steak too but
okay gotta yeah it was a so this is the
the miracle turkey yeah my my family did
a killer job but and what's the story
with the potato arra um they were
store-bought they were W you are Columbo
dude just one more thing uh there's not
a lot of uh residue on this plate I
enjoyed them my family thought otherwise
and they're like we're never buying
these again yeah it's a it's a risky
proposition
but everything else seems made right
yeah everything else was homemade um it
was really good it was really really
really good wow yeah very good
beautiful
okay this has got and by the way I mean
look at this the
colors the
spread classic
iconic simple
Perfection fall on a plate Sam this is
your
10 it is ah I knew it that and that
looks great Sam thank you how was it you
it was busing it was so
good Sam was also kind enough to invite
us over Sam and Ian for friends giving
and uh made us a meal as well so thank
is this from friendsgiving or
Thanksgiving that was Thanksgiving
that's the real Thanksgiving but we had
most of those dishes yeah we had both of
them I didn't make uh turkey though
right I just sent a photo of our second
one Sam's been cooking all
week good every time I almost took a
bite I was like I felt like we were in
you laugh you lose but it was always
delicious on the other side she served
you guys all this she served you guys
ribs oh yeah hell no dude those ribs
were crazy best ribs I've ever ever had
they look really good is this peon pie
yes love peon pie come to think
of it I didn't nobody brought peacon pie
to my Thanksgiving that's
up come to friendsgiving this I got to
say love made a what was it called
Swedish called sticky cake in Swedish
it's Cloud C cloud cockin cloud cocka it
was
sock it was really good I had uh I had
the leftovers last night Love Actually
oh well that's I I made my mother's
Swedish Cloud CA her recipe yeah I baked
it so good it was my uh baking debut God
this so wait big debut is is it on the
table or no uh no I can send you a
picture though yeah yeah I want to see
what you cooked up this peon pie looks
crazy I'll make another one I have a lot
of stuff left I'll bring it how what's
your tell me about your um recipe on the
ribs the ribs I uh smoke them on a Weber
like kettle Grill ooh um it was the
first time I've ever used my grill as a
smoker actually and I loved how it
turned out but I just make my own rub
it's just like salt pepper onion and uh
garlic and how long did you cook it for
oh go ahead uh 3 hours 3 hours yeah and
I made some steaks too I made some like
rib eyes on there as well I don't think
they jez dude
Sam got to have them ribs you absolutely
do holy smokes and too well there
it is that looks this is what's this
bread is this a roll or is that
cornbread that is a King's Hawaiian Roll
the best oh my God those are the best we
had those too they're goated why are
those so good they're so good that's
like the best bread ever what is this
Sam what is this
here um which oh the stuffing we figur
that out dressing yeah yeah okay feeling
good now here's a real mystery one this
I said was Dan mhm the Earth Cafe
uhhuh I think the only person
left
but Olivia you said you got Whole Foods
not Earth Cafe but this has to be you
right that is me Earth Cafe only did the
pies so what did you get from Whole
Foods all the food oh all the food we
got the stuffing was yeah or they didn't
no my sister and I made that but they
made the stuffing pre-made hold on you
you and your sister did this yeah what's
up about it did well I mean what
happened to the Marshall so many
marshmallows there's not a popping them
in my mouth you got to you got to cover
it and marshmallows I know next time
I'll buy a bigger bag so you used them
all just the bag was too small yeah and
I was I was snacking you f that bag up
fill that bag up sorry about the comment
about the mash or the I'm sure they
tasted great
no wait when did you talk my that's
my sister's favorite I'm going to be
honest well I was just I was just
goofing that there wasn't a lot of
marshmallows oh I totally forgive you
it's not my favorite dish I'm being
honest but Alex I love you would she be
upset if she heard you say
that she'd feel she'd be surprised I
think cuz it's her thing so she thinks
it's like so it's like our dish right
well she got to add more marshmallows
yeah you shouldn't in my opinion and I'm
just a humble mortal man but you
shouldn't see the orange I agree with
you you know what I mean if I'm going to
eat it I probably would like it like
that yeah yeah cuz sweet potato
like this dish I think it's not that
good the only reason it's good is
because it's got tons of marshmallows on
it totally agree you
know okay
so yeah and the turkey was Whole
Foods
nice nice looking plate
there not bad and of course ab and Lena
it has to be you guys the Coke Zero
that's us nice meal
yeah tell me about the procedure
here I Lena made the sides and I made
the steak oh so you guys did cook all
this yeah they were like I think those
were like were those instant Lena yeah
yeah all the sides were oh okay mhm well
this stuff is kind of makes sense
instant potatoes
are um they're okay than they tasted
fine it was like late at night the night
before I'm like I hope there's some
somewhere for us to get food tomorrow so
I just uh insta carted this late at
night so we had something oh that's nice
you just got groceries on instacart yeah
nice ni good Grill Mark
T not bad how was it cooked in the
middle right a medium rare came out good
mhm no it wasn't that great but but then
Sam made wait what was wrong with that
it was just kind of like um it was dry I
I took it I'm usually better at yeah
that but it was it was overcooked yeah
it was overcooked so it wasn't medium
rare no it was meant to be what was it
medium enough yeah I hate when that
happens happens to the best of us but
the next day we had great steak at Sam's
Place yeah that that one was so good
they were AB do you use a meat
thermometer when you cook steak no
highly recommend it you'll never
overcook it again okay get the perfect
temperature every time I started doing
that man and it it just to 10 it it's so
so important yeah I actually got one
because for when I cook chicken and I
usually don't like to cook chicken cuz I
get so paranoid like is it cooked is it
not and it drives me insane so I got one
and it's so helpful yeah I mean I
was impressed with your steak making
skills Ethan once at your house you were
you were making some steak and you knew
you knew your thanks man thanks bro
appreciate it I I think so I mean love
was there on a faithful was it When Love
arrived there was something on the
something on the
grills it was the best steak ever they
okay I'm glad you blew that
out of the world that was the best steak
I've ever had and they were thick boys
too I think it was for me too one of the
best it was like this perfect um T-Bone
yeah I think so too and the fat on there
just was crazy my God yeah it was
crazy I sent you my Chate cake too oh
let me see let me see so I think I did
pretty good you guys might I might be
getting better at this he
yeah oh yeah oh this is total
like this is upper echelon you know
what I mean I don't see any young people
in this whole last place oh that's the
one that that me L used to always go to
we lived right by here when we first
moved here you need money to enter this
store
mhm it's always that crowded too yeah
let me take a look at the menu
Earth they have a
lot Bay or South Bay Orange County La
LAX Earth at LAX
mhm Ethan you would like the Panini uh
chicken
Diablo thing dude I'm trying to get to
the menu and it's
like Panini chicken L Theo oh do I need
to pick the location get to see the menu
no it's all the same so why the
won't show me the menu okay here let me
take off
screen for a
sec I can't find the menu you go
cafes and
menus or maybe I just order I have to
click order
online we looking the stars and I was
like wow you like it's been one and a
half year
what did uh what did change like some
things that change in your
mindset like all right so figure it out
I'm I'm opening the South Bay one so I
don't dox Us in any way so I could see
the menual
okay um Pizza what do what what did you
suggest Sam The Panini chicken El Diablo
is
fire let me see they also make it in
Pizza form which is also fire
really yeah that's what I usually get
there where's that
V I love pizza I don't see it I love
people
sandwich uh yeah should be in the
sandwiches maybe it is a different menu
Pur Grill yeah there's a tab oh grilled
paninis God damn look at that steak on
bro it's vegan careful there love oh my
god sorry vegan Patty
M scary stuff so this is the L Diablo
chicken panini
time let me take a look at this it's
super
good let's see grilled cilantro
marinated chicken breast nice three
chili sauce okay thly sliced jalapenos
okay micro cilantro and montere jack
cheese that sounds pretty
good girl you are not
kidding
um fidus do you want
something you want something Budd uh uh
thought it was very very cool like I I
want to think though when I was with you
I was thinking oh yeah in the future I
will be less I mean it's me it's FS what
do I want how far gets me every
time is me it's kind of crazy how far
are these pizzas good ideal CIS I love
the pizzas that's interesting that they
have good pizzas the pizza El Diablo
that's the one you're talking about yeah
you should try that I feel like you'd
really like it holy let me get a
load of this holy dude hold on hold
the
fic hold on spicy
chicken classic it's just all that on a
pizza
that Mo the margarita don't
look too bad either you know but that's
boring rip Jimmy Buffett
dude oh my God the French toast King
dude are you're looking at my screen
yeah yeah wait that French toast does
look
nuts French toast with ice cream only in
America is that a breakfast I'll one
Olivia you want yeah let go no the
French have it too right I'm pretty sure
although to be
fair uh croissants are not exactly the
best uh healthiest food either so
m in fact I think you'd have a hard time
finding a
less good for you food than a croissant
what about one filled with chocolate
that's even that's even I don't know I
don't even know if that's worse cuz it's
taking away more space from this right
it's like 70% butter
right spinach and mushroom kiche what do
you think about that Sam I've had it I
don't like it actually okay thank you to
make up your mind man oh well hold on
down true if I'm 100% true right read
some of these super chats while you make
up your mind how does that sound go get
me the Diablo
pizza and you said they have bobies they
have boxes you should get well you don't
like anything super I don't know it's
not super sweet but their Spanish like
grenita with Boba is so good which one
the Spanish
granita Spanish granita granita
granita the Spanish granita amazing
their Boba with or sorry matcha with
Boba is really good
too God I wish I could tell the you know
these calories are like nuts man yeah
for sure which one did you suggest I I
don't see
it uh Spanish uh sorry hold
on it's called an ice Spanish grenita
but I can't all right give me one of
those get me one of those okay all right
got you thank you pumpkin pie Boba no
don't eat that we tried that it's bad
okay don't eat that man holy
smokes shame on you Earth
Cafe all right good sorry about that
everybody you know I said I said no more
ordering on the show and then you know
what happened is there was people on the
sub they were complaining they said yes
ordering on the show we demand it in
fact interesting so interesting I'm
giving the people what they
want
um all right what did you want to
confront me about
Dan uh did you are you pretending like
you don't know or well go ahead set it
up or set it up set it
up well uh for those that didn't watch
our Thanksgiving episode last week one
of the dishes that Sam brought was um
cranberry sauce I guess is what it was
supposed to represent right it was
really more of like a Jello but anyways
uh embedded or suspended in there was a
bunch of little uh little
shrimpies and uh I believe the cranberry
stuff was also garlic flavored too so it
was like garlic cranberry all different
flavors and
Ethan claimed he couldn't eat the shrimp
because he's Kosh
now that's obviously a
joke um for those that know Ethan
because he doesn't keep
kosher however it is true that he
doesn't like
shrimp
however in other
circumstances it hasn't been a problem
all right everybody let's dig in I'm not
eating the shrimp I don't eat shrimp
it's not Kosher that's I'm not eating
the shrimp I never eat shrimp no
I never ate shrimp either it's not
Kosher I did not want to eat that shrimp
so I didn't you want Shri banana yeah
yeah yeah that's some good stuff I don't
usually eat shrimp but I'm going to do
it you is it a is it a a kosher thing no
I'll say by the way oh yeah a fellow AOW
H all right this PoBoy here I'm going to
take a bite and then I'll pass it off to
you guys now I don't like shrimp I'll
just put that out there so I'm not sure
how this is going to
translate h
look at this thing looks crazy ain't
nothing po about this boy yo got him
that looks vile what is
that Dan you can take a bite of the
cranberry there's no shrimp in there
that was so nasty do that and I'm kosher
100%
always me too Ethan but you also have to
get blessed by a rabbi this bunch of
we don't keeper
me never I tell you what I wish I was a
Muslim yesterday man I would have kept
two of those things out of my mouth well
it's probably not Kosher either yeah
probably not I should have pulled that
card the the B testicles is probably the
worst thing I ever tasted and I swear to
you that taste was in my mouth all
H all right so what's your point
this is anti-Semitic is what this is so
that's the vibe I'm getting the point is
that you not liking it is not an excuse
not to eat it that's the point
okay of all pull up the clip because I
recall that I wasn't the only one that
didn't try the shrimp well I don't eat
shrimp well well good for you Dan how
convenient for you I have the actual
excuse that you were trying to use okay
so what's going to happen if you taste a
shrimp is your body going to explode uh
no but I but I don't eat shrimp on a
regular basis neither I'm me neither I
don't eat shrimp but I why not is it for
ethical reasons or is it because it's
gross no it's ethical no it's not oh so
you're better don't try and claim that
so so the eth I'm not saying that it's
better but our motivations for not
eating it are completely different cover
the this this whole ethical cover that
you run for yourself not only do you not
have to eat the shrimp but you get to be
the good guy also seems trying to CLA
let's not make it about that okay let's
not make it about that I'm just saying
you have mouth you have teeth
are you're not allergic are you would
you die if you ate it no but listen
listen okay there are lots of dishes on
that table that I don't eat regularly or
wouldn't want to eat in that context
yeah sure shrimp let's just say I did
eat shrimp do I want to eat shrimp
suspended in like a
gelatinous uh cranberry thing no did
you yeah no because we're talking about
a hypothetical situation oh were you I
didn't know if you were on this round or
not
uh no I I yeah I mean I I I took a
little nibble of the stuff which let's
Sam was there uh was there um Jello-O in
that or I think you said there wasn't
right uh in the CR like cranberry like
part of
it there was yeah I used Cherry Jello-O
oh see so that actually wasn't I wasn't
supposed to eat that either so I
up okay oh I didn't even think about
that let's watch think about it until
just now either let's analyze let's
actually look at what happened
okay cuz proof is as they say in the
pudding but in this case it's in the
jell though this is a clear case of
anti-Semitism Dan shame on
you after everything us Jews have been
through my family's Jewish I know I know
all right let's watch converted to
Judaism yeah while he was staying with
us yeah that's true there you we'll
share this one I'm kosher give me the
shrimp yeah on the
shrimp do you normally
shrip I'm playing the fifth your own he
didn't take the shrim wait you didn't
eat it either the listen yo this Crystal
knocked in here I took a bite of that
crustation can I ask a question why is
it that the only people being Target did
here are the two Jewish guys yeah why is
that both may I also add pure ashkanazi
too
100% you know which you know you know
which Jews mostly died in the
Holocaust you want to answer that
Dan s yeah my family
yeah trying to throw that in my face no
I no I mean God bless him God Rest him
here let's see I'll keep watching I'll
keep
watching here jell jell oh so you made
it earlier so it's me Zach
and oh shrimp texture it looks like aeto
it smells so strong yeah I have this oh
my God it's garlicky huh this guy says
he's from Boston and he can't eat
shellfish red everybody can eat
shellfish cian yesterday no but he he is
a vegetarian but he also is oh you're
allergic cam is actually like allergic
to shellfish yeah oh so that's why I was
giving him because uh he's from
Boston where they love shellfish but he
gets a pass he gets a
pass death is a pass
yeah well I don't know do we have a
EpiPen here I mean maybe that's not even
a good
excuse what we you know we did we have
Maddox on
standby you believe this
guy I smell it I smell it unbelievable
you want me to just take a bite of the
shrimp kind
like what did you you said is everybody
I said do you want me to just take a
bite of the shrimp I was being very bra
W she full sending dude she full send I
think we had a combo about it though but
I agree you know what after reviewing
this well let me get to the eating and
then I'll I'll make my statement sorry
it's good for you I'll f f oops I mean
I'll yeah get in there love I don't want
to laugh but I'll honestly kind of no
that's too big a bite girl I don't want
to eat the shrimp what this is love
likes it he took a bite and he was in
heaven he didn't even yeah he
yeah he didn't taste the shrimp though
oh hell no no okay all right well
that's kind love says the jelly is good
oh oh
come all right I'm going to take a bite
of the jelly I didn't even bite give me
the trash just the smell give trash
trash can oh W give me the trash can
what little bag of here
dude you good man Zach I would have
probably just aborted regardless I mean
courtesy the handing me
a trash can without a bag come on dude
you need to say
please okay next time I'm in distress
please people are saying we have weights
and fish literally or in shrimp weights
and shrimp weights and shrimp yeah wow
that's you oh a no bag can thanks for
holding back on that that was very
impressive cheers let's go together
cheers Ela too the she's pregnant
she gets to pass that's fine I hate so
here's the thing I mean listen you guys
see say I'm being a baby okay nobody
suffers like I suffer everything about
my suffering is
unique disgusting oh I'm very sens
that bad huh one little nibble
of garlic
Jello it affects me more than it affects
you guys you're very fragile yeah thank
you for acknowledging that yeah I'm very
senstive to like a little baby bring
back to the to the baby accusation so I
Was Not only was I being a baby I am a
baby cry a lot because Jews circumcise
kids when their babies Dan good point
your response
[Music]
huh what what point are you trying to
make here that you're calling Ethan a
baby are you saying you need to
circumcise him is that your point you're
trying to make here D no that wasn't the
point I was trying to make cuz that's
anti-semitic that's it's some Next Level
dude um okay here's what I'll say I
could have I'm so opposed to eating
shrimp just on the basis of it be
grossing me out I should have you're
right I I could have nibbled a up I
didn't want to eat any of that I
ate like blue cheese mac and cheese dude
did you have that one I don't you left
on that on that round no I didn't have
it but yeah it was a small bite and it
was a it wasn't a shrimp bite but uh you
know you're right I should have I should
uh get more into it and I should embrac
it for what it
is the thing is I tried to swallow it or
no I didn't actually I spit that one out
but I know if I took a shrimp bite and a
bigger bite I would just spit it out
imately I did spit it out I couldn't
swallow cuz I I swallowed a fair bit of
that I was really like who else to
defend myself lets it marinate in their
mouth like
this the because I can't throw
down I have to really chew it up I don't
know why but like who else marinates and
analyzes I
hate I just hate
everything you're like damn you've gone
to your t
gone to your happy place is that bad huh
I don't want that my
body I can get some more yeah Dan I will
say though you definitely went Gang
Busters you you ate the most of any I
think I ate almost all of them yeah was
you know what helped get that meal down
was the yummy yummy gamer Subs that we
had on the table it was delicious
factual my dude it it made it 10 times
better yeah washed it all down and
energized me and hydrated me
too all at once hey family I'm moving
from Texas to Utah in a week to be with
my boyfriend 3 years I've lived in Texas
all my life and I'm nervous to leave
everything behind any advice uh join
just stay away from the Mormons I don't
know yeah if somebody has a glazed look
watch out for the glazed donuts just be
a little suspicious Utah man you got to
watch out bro those Mormons they're
around every
corner they're
I just saw you know the the Tim Ballard
guy the uh the um rescuing the sex
traffic kids movie why can't I think of
the name of it sound of Freedom did you
watch that I've never watched it no but
we talked about it but uh I just saw
that that guy apparently because you
know he's being sued and uh possibly
arrested for all kinds of crimes
Financial crimes and then also like uh
sexually harassed passing his employees
and stuffff which is a little ironic
given the subject matter he was uh
working on a sequel to sound of Freedom
called like the city of Freedom or
something and it just came out because
of a lawsuit that uh his
co-writer another guy from the church is
the uh Attorney General of
Utah H I know I have a lead for you look
at this hey attorney general I've got a
lead for you the guy you're working with
right the Attorney General I heard he
needs to be prosecuted he's being sued
over witness silencing and fraud
claims oh the attorney general who made
the documentary with him no he was a he
he didn't but he apparently was working
on the sequel he was a
writer look at his face that man has
glazed the up that's not yeah for
sure demons in that man shiny dude
behind his eyes both of them look kind
of demons
a sound of Freedom
baby every theater's empty that was the
weirdest conspiracy that was
it's a conspiracy bro I don't think it's
a conspiracy I think it that's what
happened like there okay I I don't know
I to set it all up again and go back
it's fine yeah so yeah I mean listen
people are upset they say I've cheated
that I have to take the L I'll take the
L and I'll pledge here today for all of
you all that next year when we step up
the punishments I will partake to a
satisfying um amount in fact so much so
I'll PL
this I'll allow you guys to
fairly select the
portion that I'll eat wow wow fairly
though it needs to be made in good faith
and I'm the sole decider of
that so there you go that's my deep and
utter
apology uh to keep talking about
Thanksgiving for a sec we talk about the
disaster that befell me and my family on
Thanksgiving oh I need the video do we
have the
video I cannot find the video the video
there was a video that
pre uh
that pre- uh dated this this image I
haven't even seen this video of the
cooking experience oh of the disaster it
was so bad miss that I never wanted to
make a video like this ever so on
Wednesday I was really hyping up or I
don't know if it was Friday really
hyping up these roasted potatoes because
again I do have a somewhat iconic mashed
potato that people look forward to and I
thought I would mix up and say these
roast
potatoes are going to change the game
mhm I did a test run of them the night
before they turned out pretty good I'd
say like 80% there and I was like just
some small twinks twinks just a small
little
twinks some small tweaks and I've got
it and
so I prepared the potatoes I had a whole
lot of them I peel them I cut them them
up I boil
them the problem first of
[Music]
all I cooked the potatoes on a
Iron
Sheet the night before now Sam I was
convinced by some people in my home that
using a tin foil baking sheet would
provide the same
cooking as the Iron Sheet
and that turned out and I said to myself
tin foil doesn't get hot how is that
possible and I feel like that was the
first contributing factor to the failure
Sam do you do you um do you agree about
the tin foil
sheets um I mean I cooked all of my
stuff in tin foil sheets and it was fine
good for you it does I mean it does it
does get hot it just doesn't like keep
the heat the like when you take it out
oh is that you think it just cools off
really fast comeing with that heat yeah
really yeah I think so let me see the
tin foil science uh sheet verse is it
iron that it's usually made out of
aluminum it's aluminum oh aluminum okay
yeah ALU you don't you mean Al aluminium
for our British fans right I thought so
aluminium
jeez no tin no tin fo okay I mean
aluminum versus not your ID iron that's
the probably like like steel like
stainless steel tin steel yes steel
okay steel is harder than aluminum
obviously just T I mean have you ever
touched aluminum
Google while aluminum does increase in
strength in colder environments okay I'm
not doing I'm not I'm not hard you're
asking
for cooking I'll say
roasting the same question
mark this would be a good question for
chat gbt stainless steel layer have a
higher volume metric heat capacity
meaning that they can hold onto large
amounts of energy delivered delivering
it to your food as you add it aluminum
is a great heat conductor which means
that your pan will heat more
evenly without developing hot and cool
spots so aluminum that heat is is
apparently fine wait are they talking
about alumin baking sheet or aluminum
foil that's what I'm that sounds like
they're talking about the sheet was you
know these pre-bought
aluminum trays they're it's thin oh okay
it's not like a piece of metal it's very
malleable so it's not foil no it wasn't
foil well Ethan also didn't you say that
you heat oil in the pan in the oven or
something like that before so then the
other problem and this was probably the
biggest problem that sounds like the
biggest problem no no hold on the pro
that's not the problem that's a
beautiful technique samon I recommend
trying it the problem was that I added
way too much
oil like way too much oil like a lot I
had to drain it like three times
separately and I had to add it to
another pan I mean and and like it was
still too much oil so what what tasted
off about the potatoes the flavor was
fine frankly it was just they never got
crisp it's probably because your oil
temperature was too low that's what I
that's why I blame the aluminum cuz I
cooked it the day before at 400 the same
degree the same temperature now what
kind of oil did you use canola canola
that's a pretty low your your oil has to
has to be piping hot if you want
something to get crispy if it's not
piping hot it's just going to absorb the
oil piping hot that's what happened it
just absorbed it all Sam yeah you think
it was a I think the
foil sheet is what foiled me in the end
I think that was the big I think it was
just I I don't think it was the foil I
think it was heating the oil up in the
oh
Sam from prove it on Wednesday we can
try it on Wednesday can't try it again
I'm not I can't because it's not going
to be fresh no I think you should use
your method on Wednesday but how can I
deliver you an authentic product if I
cook it at
home
oh you are we going to cook them here
well I I don't know I don't think that
that's possible which is why I'm
hesitant to make them you backing down
no I'm never bring mash potatoes I'm
kind of bitching out you scared I said
I'm bringing my mashed potatoes what do
you want from
me potatoes what are you going to bring
Sam what kind of potatoes are you going
to bring I'm going to bring my good
potatoes that I was talking about the
other
day and do you want to be more specific
or why you being so cryptic I'm going to
be cooking mine in duck fat oh so you
are roasting them yeah okay so then what
tell me how are you going
to reheat them I'm probably going to put
them in the air fryer here okay to crisp
them back up so you cook them fully the
night before or the morning of I'll
probably do it the morning
[Music]
of that's pretty
serious I mean you can do that you can
do it right before you come over here
you're going to copy my strategy if I
tell you
anymore I'm not asking for more info
okay okay I I don't want to you know
what I mean I want you to I want you to
do your thing and I'll do my
thing that's all I've ever
wanted everybody do their
thing and everyone's getting in on it
right didn't the whole uh love said he
was stepping up um who else there was
one other volunteer somebody said this
is a really good comment from
Platypus the aluminum sheets are good
heat conductors so when you drop in the
potatoes they lose the heat super fast
as opposed to a baking tray which holds
heat a lot longer I think there was just
uh it was just a culmination of
disastrous
missteps and basically this is what I
ended this is what I ended the night I
was so disappointed people were trying
to comfort me too they're like it's good
it's good I was
like
so they weren't all mad they didn't they
were fine they were like maybe a six out
of 10 they were fine they were edible
you need to leave but I'll tell you this
of all the stuff we had for Thanksgiving
those
potatoes were not even close to
gone nobody went for second yeah that's
a shame that says it all and when I make
my mashed potatoes it's
gone
H oh man that's up dude I'm sorry
it was and and the thing I lathered it
up in like this really beautiful
rosemary garlic cilantro olive oil and
that flavor was great but it just didn't
get
crisp somebody said um Ethan's potatoes
sound more akin to roasted potatoes the
challenge is mashed potatoes no it's not
I don't think that is the challenge it's
just a potato dish what show are you
watching how dare you tell us the
challenge is wait hold on Sam you're
roasting
potatoes I I'm not really roasting them
I'm going to be like pan frying them
think that's a roast we roast well pan
frying in the oven not in the oven oh
you okay so you are going to be pan
frying we're fully out of the oven dude
okay I see we're on the Range Home Home
on the
Range and home
fries I see okay interesting no but the
challenge is just bring your your best
potato dish right it's not it's not
yeah no it was hard man no experiment I
was sitting there in the kitchen I was
just watching them and everybody's ready
to eat everybody's food's eat I'm
looking at I'm like they're not crispy
I've been here for 2 hours you see their
eyes fluttering over them you're like h
m it was so sad
no I know
[Applause]
it was an insane Thanksgiving
drama oh so that's the insane
Thanksgiving drama
uh-huh it was tough it sounds like
nobody really paired but
you so is the drama just you being
upset the drama yeah yeah that's it it
was tough for me to it was tough it was
a hard day for me yeah I get it yeah
although Ela brought um a friend over
and she cooked these pumpkin chocolate
chip muffins that
were crazy baby those were really
good oh speaking of
um cookies and desserts here's Charlie
um talking to us about uh I'm not sure
the success rate of like $28 no matter
how you spend this no matter how you
spend this a lot for some cook cookies
$7 a bag and that's still expensive but
wait can I is this an actual transcript
because I want to read it along with
them
I'm not sure the success rate of like TW
where did you get this text from I copy
pasted the transcript from the video but
I don't know if it's the same as the
sound B oh clever so it's probably just
a little off I uh there were some parts
I chopped up
okay I see $28 is a lot for
cookies anyway okay that was fun though
lots of nice fun Thanksgiving uh content
there for you
guys
mhm now we actually have a ton of really
fun stuff to get to as
well in our
document we actually had this idea no
again this was a fan idea um actually
here I want to give him credit I thought
this was such a funny
idea um what is
happening by this
user Navy a stroke
navier stro episode suggestion Zach has
to say the sound bites out loud instead
of using the
soundboard now this was number two in
the top of the show and was the plan to
do this all episode but I want to point
out we are going on two
hours yeah is it kind of late to start
like the gimmick two hours into the
episode probably could I could I give
some input on this yeah of course I feel
like it might get a little redundant
after a while yeah a whole I mean a
whole three hours of it will probably be
pretty intense for
everybody let's try it as we're going
through the stories top of the show Zach
all right my other thing is a lot of
these sounds in here are uh people
saying crazy things oh so I'm
giv
[Music]
sorry I didn't want to say that yeah
yeah I
misspoke uh so wait I wonder where it
got cut Z Zach was saying he doesn't
believe whatever he's saying he does not
condone correct these are the sound
bites speaking through him correct yes
okay so that's
fun y'all y'all are gonna freaking lose
it um a OJ Simpson went on a podcast oh
now you want to do this right when this
starts I mean I'm doing the show I feel
like I gotta play that at least so maybe
let's let's reschedule it okay CU I
agree this this is crazy yeah so OJ
um he went on this podcast that was
quick all right that was a cool segment
very good guys yay we should do it from
the top I
agree so OJ Simpson's talking about how
he
pulls guys and girls he says he's a dick
magnet was that in this clip there's so
much crazy in here it might be this
one or the one B because this thread has
a bunch of Clips on it so and now this
is OJ Simpson the Man known for
probably make a gun murdering oh no well
that's not a I mostly know him from
Naked Gun that's not he murdered someone
probably Norbert two maybe officer
Norbert literally is that toothpick
almost
here toothpick changes everything Sam um
I'll message you in Discord oh God
please don't say got no I need
something this is going to be e the only
thing keeping me going I'm on a Discord
huh
huh wait can't make this up wait why why
not read that I don't know it's fine Sam
said our dental tools were delivered but
someone stole them out of the bag and
left the
cheit dang cheit that how so we only
have cheit
that you Dan so did you order another
one or did you complain I ordered
another one and I complained must have
been an accident going to get here cuz
if I if I'm
stealing a
tooth thing I'd probably take the cheit
too at that point leave the gun take the
canoli leave the leave the cheit take
the toothpick
yeah oh that's so tragic
man all right anyway you're going to
make it worse with a toothpick I I don't
care I have to do it now it's going to
make it worse weren't you the one that
suggested
it no no I don't think you can get it
off with a metal pick didn't you say a
dentist can fix it if yeah dentist can I
think they use a oh they sand it down I
mean I don't know maybe that would work
that would work definit that do it do we
have any professional Dental sanding
tools Sam we can just use would you like
for me to get some we have a belt sander
can you order those for real yeah we
have we have a belt sander I have a a
Dremel or like a rotary tool a did you
ever oh Dremel would be perfect actually
you could totally do it with the Dremel
did you ever Dremel anybody AB I did not
I didn't get that far you could you want
me to drum on your teeth uh-huh want me
drum that
ass oh God I don't want to go to the
dentist
dude get you'll get used to him jimm me
would fly out to take care of you I'm
sure live dental work live dental
work what is oh you drew me a graph yeah
I sent you a little thing here yeah that
seems about right because the thing is
so nothing changed but your flesh
getting pushed down cuz usually it's a
nice slope you don't feel it but now
your flesh is you see a little bit
pushed down so the I agree is broken
sense I I think if you don't itch it for
a day or two your flesh going to rice up
and make that nice slope again and you
won't feel the edge but because I don't
know if it was a receding thing cuz
mouth gums then did not they tend to
recede but also I don't know if it's a
chip it just really doesn't feel like
plaque I think it is dud I you're
explaining my exact thing that I've had
for years every now and then my my gum
get slightly pushed down there because I
eat something and then a week or two
three weeks after it's going to
just come back up can you hear that yeah
mhm that's me picking at it it's very
deep and sharp and what you're doing now
wild screenshot coming out of this
episode you're pushing pushing your
flesh down even more making it it's not
that close to the flesh all right all
right thank you though but yeah this is
a good illustration actually can you
send this to Jimmy Zach
just no context just say say what do you
think all right so OJ Simpson is who's
known for probably murdering his
ex-wife is now talking about how women
can't get enough of
him uh check this out this is the
podcast it is what it
is and it ain't what it
ain't I got to get an itinerary on you
cuz your golf days switch up from your
hangout days and day you might be at the
spot I met you at on Wednesday but you
going near Sun I got to it's the subtext
here is Uncle OJ is back everybody got
that murdering
Uncle everybody got that one uncle that
probably killed his
wife how y all just sitting with him and
pretending like this dude didn't kill
two people it is what it is probably he
was
acquitted probably and then yeah but
then he also wrote a book called if I
did it he did did do that right which
apparently was never published I believe
we found out it was blocked well they
sued the the Goldman's own the book oh
and then they publish they publish it
and they changed the text so it the it
just says I did it and then the other
text is kind
yeah pretty awesome right yeah anyway it
is what it is Uncle OJ's back get an
itinerary because you moving around like
you younger than me yeah
well you you You' be surprised how many
girls got father issues and granddaddy
issues hey yo
I Jesus
Christ you know these young girls they
just don't know that I killed my
ex-wife hey y now we GNA Go I mean the
chance that he kills you is probably low
and that he's not going to want to go
through all that again right I think
even yeah like way lower even than
before yeah yeah right he's less likely
to kill you than another normal uncle
but at the same time it's still a lot
higher than an other any other person
that he'll kill you mhm interesting cuz
I mean most people want to kill someone
right homicidal Tendencies yeah with a
knife
Jesus now now we gonna go there oh I
wasn't going I wasn't going let the cat
out the bag you shocked that how many of
them girls got granddaddy
issues
right uh the gold uh The goldsteen
Goldbergs what is their name Goldman's
the
Goldman's I got to tip the beanie to
them on this one this is they they
published it like this see the if see
how small it
is says I did it confessions of the
Killer and it says if right here super
small apparently it sold quite well
325,000 all the money went to the gold
Ron Goldberg foundation for
justice dude his family is
badass they really stuck it to
him and you know he did kill their kid
so it's a pretty bad thing to
do you know granddaddy
issues yeah pretty
oh said the stats of the world got got
granddaddy
issues before we get to sports was that
what the the rapper Mace oh I don't know
who mace is some bad boy years ago with
didd he I it's just super random for him
to be there I want to know give me an
example of a female that had a
granddaddy issue that you you
encountered uh uh this one from New
Hampshire it was one that I
so I got to you know go on Uncle OJ and
where and what parts of New Hampshire
was it uh say I did like her and it
wasn't a fleeting thing I mean it lasted
at least three
days and uh oh you doing three days dude
you are a freak
bro Grandpa's feeling a little frisky
today and apparent well wait till how
you guys are going to love how story
goes oh I'm G get you
that get that to go back to
school and then she had to go back to
school after the three days I'm GNA die
this man is out here I mean he's like
everyone thinks I'm a murderer so what's
wrong with just some college
girls it's not even close to as bad as
murder he's not wrong I guess yeah yeah
it is what it is that's kind of the best
asked for this it's like yeah OJ killed
someone it is what it
is what can you
do oh s back to okay hold on where was
where did this where was y'all at she's
from New Hampshire but where were y'all
at were y'all in
Florida we're in South Beach I mean not
South Beach we were on the beach and
there's a street called Los olis
Boulevard yeah it's to me the best
Street in America okay for clubs s and
goodlooking women so
basically what you trying to tell me
this oh when I want to go out and get
some girls bring you with
me yeah
well if you want some fresh new girls
you know what I mean okay say no more
they love wait what did he say trash new
girls impressed fresh new girl oh god
dude oh wait play it again yeah I go
back and goodlooking women so basically
what you trying to tell me this oh when
I want to go out and get some girls
bring you with
me yeah
well if you want some fresh new girls
you know what I mean okay say no more
they love how old is
he uh proba in his 70s okay he looks
great for 70 76 something about the
murder did he drink their blood or
something she he looks
great looks phenomenal for 70 oh my
God you know
you look killer OJ he look don't
let uh don't let Brian Johnson know oh
yeah I'm gonna kill his son well he has
a fresh supply of his son's blood he's
more valuable alive than
dead oh man but he's really out there
getting weird ass at 70 my God
man that poor girl
where is
she right back at school he said she's
back at school he gave specifics on
Street it was I mean girls go missing
all the time people I'm going to need
some coordinates on that girl no wa I'm
reading that he met his ex Nicole at a
club she was 18 and he was 30 e oh wow I
didn't know there was that big of a age
difference oh we're seeing patterns yeah
I would yeah oh interesting it sounds
like the girl he was talking about was
probably about
18 yeah 18 to 20 yeah something like
that spring
breaker nice guy good guy do do 18yar
olds even know who OJ is at this point I
think that that's part of the strategy
they know he's famous but they don't
know what for they don't know what for
they just see him he he had a new wave
cuz the Netflix uh show about him oh
true true that probably reminded made
him look like psycho right true and it
was good I watched it it was really good
yeah they made a new cover of the book
that uh mentioned the Netflix show on
Amazon I was seeing uh if I did it
there's a new uh cover that has a
Netflix why Vsauce have it what's this
have to do with
Vsauce oh I don't know what this is I
just I thought it was funny he wrote it
oh they see they made the text Gray he
was explaining the whole book thing too
but it's funny seeing hold it they made
the text even more hard to see yeah I
did it bloody footprint what are you
trying to tell us Michael I just Googled
um OJ Simpson's oldest kid is 54 years
old too
what whoa that's crazy he's old and it's
his daughter too
54 can I see a pick I wonder if he looks
younger than
her drinking her blood or what I'll see
if we can find a recent one if she's a
public figure probably is Right somewhat
I'm seeing a bit of
that
H please God is there any dentists in
the audience that can come right now to
me what if I use like a nail
file sounds horrific that sounds
torturous I'm Des I'm actually that
desperate I would put a nail file on my
mouth right now I did see someone in
chat suggest that but no no do we have
one um I do don't put us Dan
don't ruin this for me I have a I need I
have one right here bring it bring it
bring it bring it do you really want it
Dan watch and listen I also have an
electric nail file at home that would be
perfect for this o I said bu that one
out it's it's at home I have one of
those for
Bruce you want my nail file let me start
with that and see if it helps right
Ethan don't do this bring it bring it
don't listen to them do you want Jimmy
on the phone while you do this can we
should we wash it first oh this I don't
think this is strong enough to file
teeth oh that that's metal or strong
glass I've never heard of a glass nail
pile should I wash it I'll try that that
one's
stronger oh that could work Sam that
actually could work
pretty you guys everyone's saying no
don't do it you guys don't know I know
what I'm
doing nobody has faith in
me I know exactly what I'm
doing
mhm going to file down my teeth right
now
here you going to hit a nerve or
something I'm really anxious be
entertaining it' be great at least it's
entertaining I I genuinely am not
worried though because it's such a
superficial um scratch people are saying
it's a cavity I don't know is it a
cavity is cavity caused that I don't
even know I don't think it's a
c oh of course not me neither so this is
interesting okay let's see should we
should we film
it yeah my camera Ian oh this could work
this could
work
interesting okay
so do we need a we need a light Dan can
you bring the
light Dan bailed is that bad for him I
guess do you see
it you need to help
I just got notified that the other store
I ordered from does not have the dental
tool in stock so this is all we got
today this is probably better solution
actually it feels like it might be
helping
no don't do too much I feel
like I'm
not shot is crazy sticking your fist in
your
mouth which show does this name one
other podcast where they file their
teeth Down live no you're right oh my
God I think it helped it's less sharp
wait let me keep going my
[Music]
God
Dan's back Dan I think it's helping come
watch I'm making I'm making Dan
watch this a terrible idea are you
sure in sanitary that I disinfected it
did you you don't believe
her move your tongue back there you
go I see it
shout out to Simply
nailogical that is the Hol Taco nail
file it is the best nail file ever this
is really
cool shards of glass aren't going to
fall into my mouth are they they might
probably not
no it's just
glass people eat
glass do they uhhuh does that mean some
people do it's like a trick it's not
like for food but they eat it they do do
that like magician yeah
o you look like a toddler right
now it's it's significantly better all
right it it is really working wow
very go that's crazy wait hold on I want
to do a little
[Applause]
more stand aside Mr wiener there's a new
dentist in
town who needs dentist shoot the son of
a
stop you're going to have no tooth left
stop
stop Jimmy's begging you man
stop all right let me
see how we doing it's a lot less sharp
wow okay good job I think it we did
it I think it might be fixed really dude
you're everything Jimmy wishes he was
yeah a successful dentist dude you're a
successful dentist Why Pay successful
comedian yes you got a great
hairline wow he's got it all wait hold
on his Tyler
D what else do I have that Jimmy doesn't
have my love mhm a I don't know you know
I got to love hate with Jimmy
too don't fly too close to the Sun stop
texting me on the weekends I'm scared
you're going to hit a nerve or something
uh-huh you said it was better what are
you doing now Perfection damn I I don't
this is my dental score you're making it
better than before before now you're
pushing this is why Jimmy knows dude it
not the push it's different it feels
different now uhhuh yeah cuz you shaved
part of your tooth off so do you think I
actually shaved part of my tooth off or
was it PL it's just the plaque yeah yeah
you got that little chunk a little
chunky chunk clipped off there that's so
interesting like a cuz like remember how
I was making that clicking sound
yeah the ridge is gone no click the
ridge is just no click so makes sense
the ridge is gone good job you see this
shot from earlier clicking the
mouse my God it's gone it's gone I'll
wash it it's all it's all good I can
wash it you're good I'll was it glad it
worked thank you so
much girlies girlies I'll buy you a new
one though too I me oh it's okay it's
all
good she's a friend of the show right
simp what's her
name simply nailogical simply nailogical
and uh they actually gifted all of those
to us oh it was very sweet a while ago
thank you for the gift yeah Christine is
her name is this a proprietary product
or do other people make like this
too the glass sanding tool
um glass nail files exist I think
there's this extra cute though it's
really handy and the tip was like that's
what really you know helped me in this
time of my dude yeah see that
everybody's saying we had a minor a
minor f a moment ago huh I don't know in
the chat what does that mean people were
saying minor F like it buffered for it
crash for a
second oh okay we seem to be fine we're
here yep let me may just fly a little
closer to the Sun real fast no no no no
no no no Icarus you said you got it yeah
remember the the tale of Icarus let him
cook it does feel like I might
be stop careful approaching
a it feels a little more sensitive stop
yeah probably I'm I'm going to bail
listen to your body listen to your body
stop but that worked you guys oh my gosh
G Willy
dude unbelievable all right anyway back
to
OJ ah these these young girls out
here they sure got Granda issues I I
think that was pretty much the end of
this clip I showed her the glove oh no
and I said I'll wear it if you
want some of the girls like when I wear
the
glove's been outside in
Miami you know the more you know going
viral
I'm let you know that man has a 54y old
daughter that's got to watch that
here's
more this comment is insane I want to go
out and get some girls bring you with
me yeah
well you want some fresh new girls
yeah um okay there is a lot more that I
heard girls bring you wh I got to get an
itinerary on you cuz your golf days
switch up from your it is what it is let
me check out these guys they're popping
though yeah that's uh Cameron the rapper
and mace the rapper I'm not familiar
with the girl in the middle but they
have a sports podcast I guess I mean
shout outs it is what it is andon they
pulled OJ and got him talking about oh
really I didn't recognize him I mean not
many not many people could get him to
open up about having sex with college
girls who were quick as hell and they
pursued like you it didn't really seem
they had to pry that hard they didn't
actually no not at all he was he was
willing to offer that easily yeah see
that's what I'm saying
glad yeah I'm sorry say I'm glad you
went on and straighten out what you said
cuz when you first started off with that
Ken dorsy you think was a scapegoat I
was going to tell you you don't know
because kid
dorsy he's like heo no offense bro I'm
sorry no no I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry let me see here's their YouTube
Chann don't decapitate
me don't decapitate me
bro where is the OJ one they just have
too
much too much going on here
on oh this is the come and talk to me uh
channel so is this not it I thought it
is what oh it is what it is from like uh
yeah yeah I sent that
oh thank
you yeah there it's just there's so much
good lines in it there's a few places in
the VOD you could see where the view
spikes oh true where did you see it
Ethan I actually heard it on Howard
Stern this morning um Howard is has this
obsession with OJ that's so good and
true mhm I think he's might be friendly
even with the family like they've been
on his show and talked about all that
so he's particularly invested Ron
sister was on right right one of the top
comments on this video is OJ is like the
uncle you can't wait to see at the
family reunion so true yeah everyone's
got that murdering Uncle everyone's got
that molesting Uncle it is what it is
it's just a fun
cookout oh OJ's on the grill oh he's got
like the knife
gotcha he actually did that yeah with
Dian oh he did do that holy
golly G willikers man Jimmy
Cricket Leaping Lizard because you said
you played in Super Bowl 3 I wasn't
alive I can tell you about WrestleMania
3 I can't tell you about Super Bowl 3 so
we appreciate your knowledge because us
as New Yorkers don't know about the
Knicks winning the championship nor the
Jets now I got to give the Giants the
Yankees even am met their credit and no
disrespect but Buffalo is near Canada so
we don't really even count buffal is the
city it's the state definitely but we
the only it's the only New York team
come on man this is one of the most
watch this is this is Sport let me
keep going listen but I tell you that's
a great point I like that because for
those but the part of New Jersey playing
Ain no 8 hours how long is the ride it's
a 8 Hour driving misso New York look at
that he don't even consider it no
no but but you're right that was
apparently
I'm sorry if you have something to say
oh no I a got we w a game interesting
fascinating here's another one here got
to get his name back because just more
sport
here we go this is it this has got
to be at yeah baby I knew you see what
was about to happen with Joe
burrow his hands for real but but what
I'll say is this to rep to still rep my
state outside of New York that is
CJ stra 36 part interception being CJ
you we still in it getting paid like the
quarterback I'll say this before I go
and then you gonna be air hustling you
cannot do you got to stop ping the K
negotiate Audi negotiate they're not
interested in this dude what the
they're actually interested in the
sports yeah
jeez give me extra 30 ho stop
is Trophy winner yeah I was sayman he's
a murderer but he's probably the
greatest running back of all time is he
really that good unbelievable right of
all time I I would say so oh I'm hearing
some objections from the Cameron corner
I don't think so I don't know I know he
was like real good historic like really
the real tragedy was his his comedy
career being cut short God he was
unironically really good at that in the
Naked Gun movies yeah yeah he was in I
remember he wasn't he also in Ace
Ventura no that was um Dan Marino yeah
out thank right BL is out yes please I
mean o and Guy Jim Brown are like
arguably the greatest running back this
is mindblowing that the these popular
moments aren't about be playing just as
well without they're actually interested
in as they're playing with him yeah in
the purpose of the can somebody find me
where he talks about it because these
people watching this are crazy I when
you brought it up I looked around and
that clip we watched earlier was the one
that was being widely shared everywhere
real quick uh Jimmy text me he said uh
my team text me do not file your own
teeth please that's dangerous no have
him call me later it worked who's going
to say no to me I'm better I'm curious
he's drinking a soda
now real you to the dentist is it
enough time
pass Jimmy said well they when they say
filing your own teeth down it sounds a
lot worse than what it was right or was
that just what it was I I'm sure he mas
and text him or someone else you
know Ethan's file in his teeth God damn
dude I haven't had one of those in a
couple
days in a couple days yeah I mean I
usually have like one at night I see
actually you know what it's been I've
been enjoying other Sodis like uh root
beer root beer zero I love a root beer
man I'm a root beer boy I love root beer
I'm all about it now was some
like cro I think it was actually Kroger
I was like RI Kroger I tasted
fine yeah chosen by the buffalo in 1969
Simpson would play 10 seasons for the
bills in that span OJ would set numerous
franchise record records including most
career rushing yards and highest career
rushing average wow
crazy franchise records so the bills
that's what it yeah I think it's a Bills
record them otherwise it would say
NFL record right yeah he was good though
I gotta say but him him and Jim
Brown man he was truly on top of the
world if only he didn't stab someone in
the neck and kill two people
yeah you know
you know D I'm surprised I'm not seeing
these clips on Twitter I know what the
only seeing the one how are the I'm
not even seeing comments about
it they're not interested over there
honestly this is why sometimes I I
haven't been listening to Howard a lot
but when I do there's usually like I
don't know how they find this
because nobody else is talking about it
somebody on his staff probably listens
to the show and just like they just
stalk OJ they're just cover everything
oh right you did say that they were
obsessed with OJ I mean yeah was it a JD
find I don't know he didn't say he just
played it probably
though how was there not one comment
about
it
like maybe they're deleting
stuff going from four days to six days a
week uh there it's all just football
related Everyone likes OJ oh this
comment's funny O.J is getting real
comfortable
now there you go that's one that's the
only comment I've seen peaceful vegan
Warrior being a little bit real about it
maybe he'll finally admit
it Uncle OJ getting them girls with
Grandpa
issues I will repeat myself from last
week we do not want him too
comfy yeah okay so there's there's one
sane person
here crazy I'm seeing it looks like he's
a regular guest on their show this
person says I'm tired of OJ not getting
that recognition he
deserves well he should have killed
someone
then well you you you'd be surprised how
many girls got father issues and
granddaddy issues you be shocked that
how many them girls got granddaddy
issues uh uh this one's from New
Hampshire it was one that I liked so you
should not have said that say I did like
her and it wasn't a fleeting thing I
mean it lasted at least three
days and uh he had to go back to school
you should not have said that South
Beach I mean not South Beach we're on
the beach there's a street called Los
olis Boulevard to me the best Street in
America clubs bars and goodlooking women
you want some fresh new girls you know
what I
mean not really OJ it's
pretty it's pretty comfortable as they
said you are getting too comfortable out
there man I think we need OJ to go back
inside you
know I'm going to try to find the full
clip that we can watch but I thought
that was pretty
interesting speaking of Jimmy Lee
actually I want to congratulate him on
hitting 1.2
million followers he's actually run the
bot people have run out of um fake
accounts to follow him and they just
started look at this
this same name and profile
picture bu gun
ban yeah it's for sure just AI or like
randomized
he's insisting that you call him
later if he makes it in time I mean I'm
not going to stick around no no no no no
like personal call
[Music]
oh I love Jimmy come on don't be so
Jimmy you'll never get off the phone I
have a special kinship with with Jimmy
the reason that I like him so much is
probably because I don't personally
communicate you don't have to deal with
so Jimmy trust me it's better for you if
I don't answer that
call that's that's actually true yeah
that's actually very true yeah call into
the show Jimmy I don't want to talk to
you start talking to Jimmy regularly
Jimmy why I want to talk to you
personally call to the
show you still want him to call in yeah
he's
available I don't even know about what I
forgot I just want to hear his voice
what's about your teeth my teeth are
fixed it's legit fixed the ridge is gone
okay well then no need for Jimmy can put
him back in the dust bin of History
um yeah but this is pretty f i legit
think that he they probably ran out of
fake accounts yeah and they're literally
making new ones just for Jimmy like bu
gun bass is a ill person I don't know
1.2 million fake followers I don't think
anyone's everever bought that much
before cuz at a certain point what we
think the real proportion is cuz surely
some you know fans or whatever 50,000
maybe 50 I think yeah 50 of most
mhm Jim yeah I think 50 Jimmy said he
can call on in five minutes you know
what's a shame is that if he actually
just had 50 and had like a good
engagement mhm his page would be cooler
I feel like you could see the real
activity yeah I didn't like that recent
post though where he was it was a
Thanksgiving post where he was at
Thanksgiving dinner and he pulled a
Tommy gun out of the turkey and started
killing Native Americans yeah and he
says it is what it is I say yo bro come
on dude that's up not on
Thanksgiving no it's supposed to be why
Tommy Gun I don't know I just a
cartoonish I don't know yeah no I feel
you it's just somebody tell Jimmy that's
not era appropriate right no it's not
what would be more air appropriate just
a rifle a sword like a mus musket or
something
he all right congrat blunder bus perhaps
a blunder bus m i with blunder
buses an
arabus
succubus um Jimmy also shout out was on
Newsmax again he's become a regular
there this is his second appearance on
Newsmax I
believe and his choice of Network people
are saying
listen
again I maybe I'm being too CH
charitable to Jimmy I think he's only on
Newsmax is because they let him come on
I don't think he's like what I'd be S
let me ask I'm gonna ask if he watches
Newsmax because that's obviously
concerning if he does well he's
conservative he is so the demo dude no
but's Prime demo small business
owner hold on there's a difference
between being conservative and being a
Newsmax watch her yeah there is but
Jimmy Lee is so the
guy he's so the guy that would watch
Newsmax also I noticed in his Clips he
never actually gives any kind of
meaningful analysis so you don't say
he's there for the jokes anyway here it
is come back to Sunday report SNL Alum
John litz recently tearing into the
liberal late night talk show host for
their
hyper not for you guys
John of their once comedy shows
basically he's saying they're doing
monologues on politics but it's all left
leaning this man said he says John
Lovitz came out and said this and
basically this is what he said show the
clip what did he say not important
basically he said that libs are dumb and
conservatives rule
anyway just trust me can you actually
look up what he said like I'm curious
what they
extracted to uh summarize it in that
way love it's taken specific but Jimmy
Kimel Steven coar Seth May Myers um and
he's saying that they're funny but
they're too politically one-sided I mean
he's not wrong the whole the
whole the whole political gimmick they
have is kind of tiresome even though I'm
like totally agree with them politically
but it's like it's very ey rolly it's
like all right dude I yeah I agree and
it's like all three of them do it they
yeah at Le like I guess credit to Jimmy
Fallon for like actually being the one
stand out that like isn't leaning into
all that and he's actually the most
popular I think too or at least was uh
he was I don't know if he still is Ian I
think Greg gutfield is the king
of L now Co at least has his background
is in in political commentary for Co it
makes more sense yeah but these other
guys I don't know yeah focusing too much
on the far right politics and not enough
about the entertaining of the audience
so what are we going to do we're going
to talk to some comedians about this and
get their take on it join me now is the
Jersey Outlaw Jimmy
Lee what's so funny
Zach this C to him he really believes in
those glasses eh I mean it made me laugh
dude I mean
he's the man Jimmy won
over so wait I have the quote from it
hold on wait where'd it
go oh okay so here go ahead Jimmy with
comedian Chrissy mayor um I want to get
to what are your thoughts Chrissy first
off on John lit's comments do you agree
with him you never said what the
comments are tell us what did he say man
oh I found I guess it's the same thing
Olivia do you agree with my
paraphrasing I agree with John 100% look
he was on SNL between 1985 and 1990 some
of the funny yeah relevant 198 he was on
SNL
1985 perfect uh position of hey I don't
want to knock John loves too
much he is he is kind of a legend I
agree I like John L I don't know I don't
know anything about his comedy now or
his political views or anything but like
in that era you know every era of SNL
has like its hacky people or whatever
but he was funny and I loved his show
the critic too I yeah here I have the
quote he said I don't like it I don't
like it they were comedy shows and now
except for Jimmy Fallon they've all
become very political and for me it's
just too much that is L that is okay
there's more I mean Johnny Carson would
you know he would do two or three jokes
about whatever president was up to but
that was it they were entertainment
shows he said I know all those guys and
they're very nice guys is very talented
I know Seth I know Stephen I know Jimmy
they're all super funny but when they
start doing the political stuff like so
onesided it's like and that's all it is
the whole thing it's just like that's
not the shows that I used to go on you
know it was The Tonight Show and da I'm
pretty sure a lot of them are making fun
of Biden though aren't they I mean I
don't watch this I used to watch I
thought you watch jimble Kimble not
anymore not anymore I'm out I haven't
watched him in years either so but I I'd
imagine there I mean Joe Biden is pretty
good
fod he continues it's their show they
can do whatever they want but you're
asking me do I like it and I'm saying No
this seems like a fairly reasonable take
love it's Contin not too charged you
know if I want the news I'll watch the
news I'm not watching those shows I'm
late night their late night
entertainment not politics except for
Jimmy Fallon and they keep getting mad
at Jimmy why why don't you go into
politics because he's doing a silly like
escapism entertainment show yeah I mean
I that's a good commentary the only
thing I think that they're latching on
to is he said it's so
one-sided but when they started doing
the political stuff I mean that's the
only one that kind of uh gives a hint of
what you know oh would he really feel
this way if it if it was the other way
around or whatever but the whole rest of
the comment seems reasonable more hey
just stick to Comedy on the comedy show
kind of take which okay fair
I think it's pretty funny that Newsmax
somehow created a whole segment from
this John love it it was on SNL
1985 well I guess we see why they didn't
show the clip I mean Jimmy was uh in his
prime then he was a 90s kid you know
late 880s early 90s that's true big fan
he had hair then yeah lots of it he
still has
hair I shouldn't make fun of him for
that got a great
hairline and most successful years of
SNL and he knows these guys are funny
he's come up with a lot of these other
late night hosts uh through improv and
either LA or Chicago or New York so he
knows they're funny guys he just knows
and this is John has been sounding the
alarm on this for years now and not only
do all of the late night hosts uh have
to be live why do they have a live feed
of Rafa
Crossing what what are they waiting
for oh oh you were covering it so I
wasn't sure where talking oh yeah here
they have a live coverage of the Gaza
Egypt position is crazy what the
oh this girl's a comedian too
Chrissy
Mayer okay so she's a comedian she's
actually giving commentary Jimmy is
incapable of focusing it's quite good
Wing but look at all their guests look
at the types of guests that they'll have
on they have to all have the right
politics that being said there's nothing
less funny than conservative comedy as
much as like they're for sure
conservative comedy is truly the
god offest you could ever watch
well and getting on one of these shows
used to be a huge honor that could
Propel a young comedian's career for the
rest of their lives and if you're a
young well okay when uh Johnny Carson
was doing it there was like a hundred
million people watching it live or
something like it was literally the only
show on TV yo let me read you this
paragraph from uh This Woman's uh
Wikipedia page go ahead in 2021 an
article in the new Republic examining
compound media said mayor had delved
deep into Q andon conspiracy theories
believing and spreading them that is and
attended the protest at the Capitol Hill
on January 6th she was there she was
there here's a quote from her I was
there and anybody who was there on the 6
is like Blown Away by how like
inaccurate the media coverage is I Saw V
it was all filmed lady we watch in real
time dude I was watching it live as
people were scaling the walls like a
literally like a zombie
apocalypse she was there though so I
love the Casual emission of that so
that's news Newsmax is the pro January
6th net
basically comic who comes off even a
little bit right-wing or a little bit
right of Center or expresses passion
about free speech or any of our
amendments uh you're going to be seen as
basically a Trumper and any of our
amendments name
one oh you're a fan of the amendment's
your
favorite I like all of them they're all
good
amendments that would be a good a good
gotcha by the way Johnny Carson had 50
million people watching
live uh Johnny he was the goat I don't I
mean that was uh the finale so obviously
I think the viewership
was oh it was consistently that was a
different ER of TV if you look at it now
I think like these oh it's pathetically
bad now the top of them has like a
couple million live I think
yeah um which is pretty wild I looked
everywhere for this OJ clip I wonder if
they cut it I've used the transcript
search and that I wasn't seeing it in
there either they cut it I think they
cut Poss I was looking through
transcript daddy is Grand I had
everything yeah the whole transcript I
was searching everything he said in that
sentence and it it didn't come up MH w i
through it twice yeah so is it possible
that it's like a patreon or like a BTS
thing it could have been uh in another
yeah I mean maybe they have something
like that let me
check that's crazy you're not going to
get these opportunities so a lot of
these Comics will adjust their jokes
their online personality so that they
can get these opportunities and the ones
that don't you're just not going to see
them on late night TV Jimmy I got to get
you in on this conversation what do you
think um are too political and I guess
if they're going to do them why not go
both sides take why take shots at the
Republicans if you're going to do that
why take some shots at the first of all
that is idiotic they do they always make
fun of Joe Biden it's just I mean we're
assuming that they do they do it that
seems pull up his monologue pull up
Jimmy Kimmel's monologue most recent
monologue we'll get claim if we show it
but I can check what the subject matter
is I'm sure that they do how do they
not he's like a lost
let's let's go to his YouTube
channel and just
see what he's been cooking
on the Democrats too I think I think it
should be like back in the old days when
Corson had comedians on and gave you
know us us Little People a chance to
platform I mean my opinion is I think
Jimmy Kimmel he's a great comedian I
mean he's told me that many many times
um but I mean the irony of course is
he's obsessed with getting on Jimmy kiml
yeah if he's going he's going to to do
political stuff he probably needs a
laugh track my opinion
yeah I think you got a laugh track right
there Jimmy dead
nervous he had that skit about the
vaccine a couple years ago he should
give him shot he should give himself a
shot in the heiny give him a little
energy I mean he passed away two weeks
ago nobody told him I mean I told him my
I mean but we we got to get the little
people back on the the was that
clip
go oh it's the the fouchy
ouchie he's was that from like three
years ago give him a little energy I
mean we got to get the little people I I
love how Jimmy like he'll say a joke
with zero consideration
at all to the subject like he'll do that
he died two weeks ago nobody told him
joke about Jim Jimmy Kimmel who's a spry
energetic dude much younger than than
Jimmy Lee like it just it's not
applicable at all to him but he still
does
it Jimmy made fun of Biden turning 81 6
days ago thank you Olivia Biden 2024
older than kitty litter I don't even
know what that means but yeah that's the
monologue what does that mean kitty
litter I think kitty litter was invented
within Joe Biden's lifetime yeah I saw
that fact going around at some point
probably related to that he also showed
toasted corn
flakes onfly toilet paper these are all
things that are younger than Joe Biden
so Betty Crocker Betty Crocker is
younger than Joe Biden so yes they
definitely make fun of Joe Biden a lot
I'm I'm I'm sure of it yeah I mean it
was a safe assumption but I just I don't
watch it so the problem is one of them's
old and then the other one tried to
overthrow our democracy so right the
scope of it is
different we'll back on the platform and
give us a shot you know and do our art
and love what's uh Chrissy what's the
state of SNL right now in your
opinion uh none of us watch it none of
us watch it and we you know every year
you'll see list Comics to watch or new
writers hired for SNL and they they
might be diverse looking but there's no
diversity of thought there's diversity
politically um it seems like if you're a
member or a writer of one of these shows
that's got to be incredibly creatively
stifling and you got to think about it
John if they're not uh listening to the
viewers if they if they're not she's
annoying where's Jimmy okay back to the
jokes uh Jimmy is actually in the
waiting room is to connect ironic if you
uh Jimmy of these two comedians the one
complaining about
politics is this political lady right
the one who's just doing stick and
trying to make people laugh that's Jimmy
Lee true that's what John love was
talking about
that's that's a great observation thank
you doers and Real Americans totally
agree Jimmy I'm giving you the last word
here what's the state of Comedy right
now the state I know Griffin's making a
comeback and I was talking to her and I
said to make a comeback to her you
actually got to be a little funny I told
her that I said the rate she's going uh
she's going to go from a c Lister to a d
Lister real quick I gave her real good I
don't understand that that's sound a
joke I me okay okay I said hit the sub
does that guy have a set of
trains that's too funny all right we got
to leave it there Jimmy thank you for
coming on appreciate it as well hey John
could I could I ask you a favor yes
could you tell the people in England to
eat the muffins for Christ's sake I'm
steamed up and they're English muffins
I'm a little aggravated maybe you can
talk what he did he's doing his English
muffin routine but I've never heard
those Hold On Christ sake I'm steamed up
and they're why is he telling me to tell
it English I don't think they're related
you think that guy's British he's gone
Rogue I I've heard him when we did that
uh day of filming with him he said that
to British people but not to American
people so it's kind of that's that that
kind of he'll say any joke to anyone
without any
consideration hey tell the English there
with the muffins favor yes could you
tell the people in England eat the
muffins for Christ's sake I'm steamed up
and they're English muffins I'm a little
aggravated maybe you can talk to the
king I'll see what I can do I'll see
what I can do than you thank you very
much what what was the the maybe he's in
the UK no but what's the joke he said
English eat your English muffins I'm
steamed up I'm steamed up all right
Jimmy I it's going to be fast I promise
there's lots of mutiny in the chat it's
it's stop trying to make Jimmy Lee
happen stop trying to make Jimmy guys
I'm going to be fast I promise every oh
wait a minute Jimmy Lee the Jersey
Outlaw is not here oh okay well that
then then Rejoice oh that's James weer
James Dr James weiner is here oh never
mind never take the glasses off Dr James
Wier wait I don't want the glasses I
want the dentist Yeah we actually need
we need dental advice you're making a
spect how's your day going Dr James
weiner the dentist Ethan is here there
there's the last coat to prove it did
you do put the lab coat on what kind of
dental work did you do
today we did a a crown a denture a
three-unit bridge and fillings and just
normal stuff today Mondays are generally
busy I wanted to ask you a dental
question the back tooth I have on the
bottom okay the two little ones in the
front on the
bottom let me see I'm just yeah these
two here Zoom zooming in zooming in yeah
all right I hope you didn't file them
down yourself well hold on so on the
back just over the weekend there
appeared a really sharp Ridge on the
bottom of my front tooth that every time
I talk my tongue was rubbing on it and
driving me crazy so you may have you may
have a
chip oh hold on hold on hold on hold on
right take your finger out open wide sir
I don't see anything really Ethan you
may it doesn't look like you chipped it
a lot looks like possibly you may just
need to go to the dentist and I have to
smooth it you may have just I did that
though CH a little bit so and again not
to step on your profession but I took a
nail file and I shaved it down and I
think it worked yeah but you should
never do that I have these different
Bears when I do little stuff like that I
don't charge patience takes me about a
minute it's called an enamel plasty
where you smooth the enamel to to out
and polish it
and um you should never as a as a
patient ever do your teeth you always go
to us that's what we're there what's the
risk well I think you didn't do much
harm because it doesn't look like it's
it looks like anything it's just the
tiniest chip and you smooth it with a
nail file thank God but I go to your
dentist in the future I definitely would
not do
that well thanks for that Jimmy how was
I saw you on Newsmax you were great yeah
yeah well worried about you because I
felt bad I'm in a business meeting and I
was texting Zach call me later you know
when you're done but it it sounds like
uh then my team's texting me you better
text Zach Ethan's fing his tooth there
people are text me and I'm like Zach
tell him not to do that you you don't
want to ever be your own dentist you
want to go to the dentist well what if
you can't afford it I mean dentists are
expensive well I don't think with you
you have to worry but I mean most people
have insurance that come you know so um
but please Ethan you're you're a friend
and I love you and I don't want you to
do anything to harm yourself don't ever
do that please okay well it's too late I
did it well don't do it again all right
thank jimy yeah all right Max we we did
we did good we just had a small spot
with another comedian and uh I want to
thank Newsmax and John Glascow he was
the host and uh they're just very nice
they were talking about um yeah is he
British he could be but he didn't have
that accent but they were talking about
how late night
TV you said tell everyone in England
about the English muffins yeah I was a
little steamed up because the people in
England when I went last time nobody
eats the muffins I said they're called
English muffins I wanted them to go over
and talk to he's not
English well he he he goes over he knows
people he knows a lot of people okay so
you have Insider info about him yeah so
just to make long story short um they
talked about that the late night's too
political and it should be more like you
know when I was young and Johnny Carson
was on and they had comedians on and
they gave comedians a chance to platform
that's kind of what it was and I agree
with John litz he's the one that that
said that and he was in the New York
Post and Chrissy mayor was on a very
nice girl she's a comedian and that girl
a little more serious what's that yeah
she was did you know she was at January
6th what do you mean by that she was at
the capital on January
6 no I don't know any I don't even know
who she is to be honest
uh they put they put two comedians on a
panel I was one and she was one she was
more serious so I so I was figured I'll
be the I'll be the funny guy tried to be
the funny guy anyway all right Jamie
thank you so much I just wanted to check
in say hi hope you're doing well I love
you guys all right okay I'm glad okay
promise me next time
e go to your dentist and whatever you
need they'll do just find a nice honest
person all right I will I will thank you
Jimmy all right I love you guys Happy
Thanksgiving again everybody have a good
night good night love you Jimmy love you
guys bye
now what a guy I mean come
on he's a dentist wow he all us from his
dental office that's
awesome this pizza's Crazy
Sam yo that shit's really good and super
spicy
damn oh my
God
oh my this is way bigger than I
thought what holy oh my God that's
huge they made it look so small yeah
what the I thought it was like a
tiny little piece dude what it looked
like a little square it looked like a
little toast dude so wait what
is that I don't know what flavor is it
strawberry and
toast I want to see you cut into it oh I
want to see what it looks
like
looks soft oh yeah it's
fluffy let
me bread looks like cake really nothing
in here just looks like cake oh my God I
wait can I try it yeah come over here
dude I want to see what all the fuss is
about it's really just bread I think I
haven't soaked in egg you not no Al so
they they soak it in egg there you go
it's good though good little sweet treat
just a tiny little little treat it's
like hollow bread which is it's
delicious gorgeous bread Dan is dancing
what did you get
Dan I got a portabella mushroom uh
Panini and it's bomb dude so
good and how much was the order just out
of curiosity probably so
much me look do you like your pizza
Ethan it's really good busting it's
busting it's busing it's very spicy too
which I like uh total with tip was 185
woo Jesus I mean I guess it's like 10
people 10 people 11 maybe even uh 1 two
three if
you us here well that that's with Bowl
that's true 185 divid by
10 I mean that's not bad $20 per person
I guess for fancy lunch oh my God that's
not that
[Music]
bad that's for nine people cam didn't
get
anything good thing you what happened
cam you didn't even ask for food today I
just wasn't hungry today oh man yeah you
looked like you were eating what are you
doing over there yeah what was that I
was about to go to the bathroom
actually we also got like two fancy
drinks is another
thing two fancy drinks what does that
mean did you try your yeah you got like
a blended Boba right oh we just got two
fancy drinks yeah ah it's just you on
that Boba train it's pretty good it's
just it's like
a it's basically just a frappuccino
though is it I think that thing is so
good it is very tasty but it also was
worm in me I call it
cappucino um I call this cappucino all
right so that's Jimmy nice checking
in people give me such a hard time about
eating like I I lately I moved the mic
away from me
uhhuh there there's no way they can hear
me chewing from with the mic
here right
all right m
whatever H Let's see we have a so much
to get
to uh somebody get to we're almost at
three hours I know we barely did
anything in terms of we're on top of the
show still oh God I love him I love him
I'm obsessed with this
guy there's like a whole subculture on
Tik Tok just about this guy and I'm I'm
obsessed huh he's so awesome he he's
dancing like super chill hold on wait
wait wait wait wait he's like super
chill he's got this really chill
style and they all know the same dance I
wonder where this is and then but then
all of the sudden when it's comes his
time for the
move I've never seen anyone pull a move
like this watch this here it
comes ready whoa
W what is that that's sick
dude that guy's a
star isn't that sick he's busting down
dude um I've never seen that move before
and he's so good at
it there's even I saw this this guy has
like a fan club yeah well now that that
video went viral yeah like even now um I
saw this on my timeline and I was like I
got to tell everybody there's like
somebody already made this
I mean it has 77,000
likes oh he's so
awesome oh he's so
awesome yes he's so awesome so that's it
I love him I just want to give him a
shout out whoever you are wherever you
are we love
you you're
special
we love you you're very special there it
is all right if you were just speaking
the sound bites you could have said it
instantly is it weird that I do this
like a
child if I don't have a napkin no all of
your mannerisms behavior and everything
very nail file childlike I felt very
juvenile doing
like H little
wipy that is such a toddler move you're
right I know I don't clearly like the
exact yated like you don't have the
Precision to like like this so no depth
perception I think the superior move is
this on the
shirt Brother inside you do it on the
outside I ins Brother inside your
clothing I don't feel it or like I
didn't want to do it on my sleeve I feel
like it's grosser to get it on my
clothes cuz I can wash my hands oh you
did it on your hand yeah like yeah back
of the hand the old back of the hand
move anyway oh thank
you new chiropractor dropped I know you
guys don't like it some of you don't I
love
it
but listen when something good drops on
my feed I'm I'm G to share
it and this one was good never stop this
one I was more obsessed with the sound
than
anything but listen to the
relief
I'm it's like it's like a blood C oh
my she say no yeah that sounds like he
sounds like um Tom from Tom and Jerry
stepping on a nail all right oh yeah and
he's not only is he screaming no he's
grabbing his hand and forcing him off
him look at this
no oh feel bad for him
Jesus good job good job he just good job
this guy that's real this is how you
this is how you standing the last two
days last two days you've been standing
like this is here in my knee and your
knee okay when I was taking out trash
and I up sometime I
yeah so so my head yeah yeah this one
down for yeah you can't put that I'm
doing yeah better yeah it feels good
what is the science behind
that I mean I'm not a doctor but I'm not
going
to that scream is so
horrible good you got the SC okay take a
break
scream
flexors push this
one what the and that one was good
really good he it seems like he tricked
him or something like he didn't see it
coming at all push this
way why do he sound like a
cartoon thank you
sir all right it's all good in the end
it was a rough ride oh he's crying get
there and who be bad yeah oh yeah
no like he's in horrible pain he's
clearly suffering immensely poor guy
W but now he can walk got a little pep
in his step now look at that the thing
is in my opinion he's going to get home
probably later today or the next morning
and be exactly where he was before yeah
he's probably got adrenaline in his body
right now yeah yeah in a
life-threatening situation yeah he's
he's ready to
run that's not wrong I think is that
from that
[Music]
video do this in flter flight or fight
mode totally yeah let's see what else
he's up to let's see this one's 8
million oh God it's not just one of
these weird of course it is dude all
right let me see so knes good on this
side hit we've talked about this but
there's a
whole genre of chiropractors that just
do like girls in y yeah basically right
his hip is good here but it looks like
it's lock right here at the side joint
we're going to
go
one two
one deeper in there so we go perfect so
that helps a lot but open up the side Jo
right here
specifically perfect how that feel
awesome yes all right now face me on
this side look his sleep on his shoulder
can stop so he's good on this side why
did he upload this like that's kind of
cuz it got 8 million views I know but
like dude you're a doctor you're a
doctor he's
not what the man this one oh this
one has 22 million holy got that
not okay we have she looking straight up
you can see that I can literally you see
what I mean there's a big gap here
between her actual neck why you top of
her thoracic spine so this is the
thoracic spine this is cervical spine I
can literally hold on to it and there's
a big gap from here to there we need to
fix that because that over time will
swell up to a point will get bigger and
bigger you can see that you not going to
move her bones dude permanently sort of
swelling up so what we need to do is we
need to strengthen her deep neck flexor
right here to push that in right by
itself you can see if I go like this
look at how much better it is so that
Gap got a lot smaller you got to tuck
the chin in you got to hold that here
you're holding that for like 20 seconds
three times a day elbows elbows two
steps back lean into the wall open up
and you're going to go well that's good
that's stretchy stru like
low that's like the only good advice
that you can actually get from a
chiropractor so okay that's what I've
always said we're talking about this a
lot of CH like there is overlap between
like physical therapy and actual
medicine it's just the part that is
actually from the tradition of
chiropracty comes from a guy who talked
to ghosts or learned it from a ghost all
chiropra sh so happens that they get
some stuff from Physical Therapy
whatever's or whatever other discipline
yeah yeah and they incorporate it and
that's fine but yeah the the the
cracking bones part does
not sounds cool must be good and it very
well may even feel nice in the moment
you
know
um oh God what is this look at this out
hold on look at this outfit little tight
there where the do you get one of
those what is this it's a onesie what
you talking about what are you talking
about like a onesie like everything from
toes up yeah they sell those are like
back in right now you get them on
Amazon they more people are wearing like
one pieces like people go outside and
walk around like that with like little
Ugg
boots maybe it's just because of
her giant knockers that other attributes
I think she has a fake ass too
you
so oh my god dude
dude it looks like he's shooting a
turret right there when he's
behind her back did the thing is here
I'll go back to that for you AB thank
you
[Laughter]
um just remember guys this is a serious
quote doctor Dr
RZ let me see what else you got
here Dr RZ his name is Dr
RZ really no look at his account not RZ
Rez doctor I'm going to need a Rez after
visiting
you oh he does the cops too the C oh not
the cops I can't watch that no me
neither she's back or he just reposting
it all right all righty all right we got
we
love we get
it red I do feel bad for that guy
but that's the funniest scream I've ever
heard I I that's
why like you could straight up just
enter that into the movie database of
alltime classic sound bites anytime
someone's falling off a bridge or
something yeah the willhelm
yeah
um oh no we got new Big
Nick oh no what do you mean oh no oh yes
I sent this I forgot yeah such a long
weekend I'm not used to
it our big Nick is out
[Music]
let's see oh yeah he plays a really sad
depressing song
like
yeah it's like one of these whatever so
he's sad what is he sad
about a music video Dojo cast dressed up
as a demonic creature has 21 million
views meanwhile a music video worshiping
God has less than 7,000 this speaks
volume about our society I think it
speaks more about your music
[Music]
sucking like let's not let's not factor
that in I mean that's important
to the Quality the enjoyability
certainly should
matter um
Nick yeah so he's really sad about this
man he's really throwing his all into
the acting performance there isn't he
that's a new reaction meme right
there and also I think this actually got
a lot of views on his Tik Tok account if
you find it I linked it down below in
the dock oh thank you let me see here
yeah here it
is and I wonder if people went and
listened to
it dude CHR no wonder he likes Christian
Tik Tok you could post any dumb and
people come and ride for you this is so
sad like this is the dumbest video Let's
see bro keep spreading the word your
reward is in heaven
I like goofball
editor big Nick sucks some major ass so
I think it's pretty deserve because DOA
cat is way bigger you oh yeah let's not
even she's like world famous bro
Superstar
yeah you just don't hit as hard I'm
sorry well let's hear can we listen to
his um a two months versus one day as
well give it time give link me to Big
Nick and Jimmy Levy no longer
slave big Nick let's he I mean Jimmy he
got Jimmy the beard Levy should we check
this before is that the bomber the plane
bomber it is the plane bomber the plane
bomber uh he's up to 40K 40K views here
praise God a little better Praise Jesus
that's a cool shot at did he
uh did he bleach his hair oh wow for God
Mr Levy looks great
um are you are you checking it Zach I
can yeah check it up uh in the past his
videos haven't gotten claimed so I guess
uh that's true and I but yeah we should
still check it I love watching it man
they kind of look alike and that shot
when they said there oh that's
interesting but just that's little Nick
on the left there yeah if big Nick ate
Little
Nick okay what he's literally twice his
size at or at least yeah at least big
Nick and little I'm trying to find a
frame where I get a closeup of this
bleach blond hair but he seems to be
covering it at every opportunity he can
yeah he doesn't like it I don't think he
does like it oh there he
was so yeah not not good um as we wait
for the the the test here
mhm um I just want to say just be a
moment that God is great right and true
we live in a society
where some dumb
Jesus Rock by a
random only gets 40,000 views man and
doat world famous
superstar 30 million it's disgusting
makes me want to puke and and
piss but in the
meantime shout out to this Aussie radio
uh station host who's playing the Bop of
the summer the Bop of the
Fall so shout out to Australia we love
them out there huh Charlotte thick I
believe her name is based on the
username oh with Chloe on and look there
is nothing that makes me feel like more
of a millennial when I
hear and look there is nothing that
makes me feel like more of a millennial
than when I hear all this crazy new genz
tick Tok humor uh Sam Temple of the
hatre podcast uploaded this recently and
I honestly can't understand what she's
trying to say can anyone help me out
last night we let the rler talk even was
getting red up by baby gron he said that
yach
was any zomers out there that can help
me please give me a call I need some
help what does this
mean right now I have got the real
version of Last Night by Morgan Wallen
on love her shout out let's get it on
the airway so great I love that I sent
it to my mom and she called me
immediately she was like oh my
god look like a legit setup there her
talk up was great yeah she's got good
um how do you call that she could do the
weather really good and like like
to of the morning like a good radio
voice yeah right not the voice it's also
the delivery the talk up the talk up the
enunciation very engaging very engag I
think Zach has got it it's the talk up
it's the whole Cadence it's the how you
hit the things on music Talk the morning
to you it's like that 15 seconds before
the vocals come exactly exactly no claim
thank God no claim Jesus no media claim
Jesus is
great
yeah Praise Jesus praise him let him
know uh let me pull up the music video
let them know you care no longer slaves
it's
[Music]
called voice always M me up this
doesn't have more views
[Music]
dude
me down my life is full of peace I'm
serving Jesus now but this world is so
Let It
Be
[Music]
theam steady working try to poison all
our brains the B my weapon Holy Spirit
in my veins I know where they sh this
because I've seen those sets
before you know where he filmed this you
said yeah cuz these are these are like
standing sets at a place here in la ah
okay interesting and they just like have
all of these things so they probably
just rented it for a day looks like they
rented three of them to be it's all in
one like yeah just different different
rooms or whatever got itain there's
nothing they can do about it there power
in his
and he
want the Gat of Hell will not prz Jesus
[Music]
com should we go to this location and
reenacted or something we could that'd
be fun use all the same exact sets yeah
same set that's pretty
funny is a spiritual war so we got to
wake up and we for our we won't never
see any change I know it's hard it makes
you into slave it takes you right down
to the grave but you can turn your god
promise that is not too late my heart
hurts for the broken
see looks like one of those places at
the mall you take Instagram photos just
the sets I took my niece last year for
Christmas right you should take big
Nick next year treat
him no longer a slave with Jesus I
AMS the world SE on those yo you're
that's probably true wait hold on he
this is the same look I know it's so
creepy the beard the hairstyle yeah it's
spot on it's huh
wow like big ni he definitely is going
for that I mean that's the very specific
look isn't it 100% or maybe not I don't
know I mean they do look Alik yeah
okay to the world that's full of pain
his kingdom lasts forever and I know
with him rain my eyes are set above cuz
the Earth will pass away and it's down I
know his will never fade people always
always change only
to
only he didn't give his only son Jesus
Is God he gave himself but not really
because he came back to life and
ascended he didn't give anything at the
end of the day Jesus came back and he is
God anyway isn't that right Jesus Is God
yes yes Jesus Is God yes therefore they
are simultaneously the same being and
different beings and so therefore
explains to me how he gave up his only
son he found like a life hack around
it it's like well he just came back to
life so where's the sacrifice God I'm
not buying it Checkmate theists
Checkmate big
Nick there's nothing they can do it
there's power in his name and he want
intoed the Gate of Hell will not Prevail
Jesus com to sa so
tell we're no longer
slaves praying at the diner what you
praying at the diner with your homies
yeah I'll pass the message along it's
funny because obviously like you said
Dan they don't have any choice in set
yeah so they're just forced to sit here
and pray in a
diner with a little hot dog sign best in
town
right
[Music]
yeah yeah okay yeah I mean this should
definitely have 30 million views it's a
outrageous it's so true it's so
up it says so much about our
world
today let me see the
comments we're no longer slaves amazing
song totally loved it may the Lord
continue to bless you with new thoughts
to inspire that's what I'm saying like
the Christian audience is they're so
they're starred for Content they're so
easy like you you could serve them a
giant on a platter and they'll eat
that up that's what they're doing
here my boy big Nick big Nick snapped in
the
spirit love these lyrics the vocal
effect when Big Nick voice drops lower
sounds so
cool it was really cool when you weren't
making him sound like a
chipmunk really like the parts where you
didn't have him three octaves rub see
that's they're living in this alternate
reality where his music is
good and everybody I saw some people
saying they liked it in the chat so oh
okay well there it is so I mean they no
longer let po let's poll and answer
honestly you don't have to say it sucks
on our listen I don't I don't even I
don't need the poll to know this song
sucks did you enjoy no longer
slaves you know what I uh no it's
sucked I'm calling 80% sucked not bad
[Music]
and all right let's see
everybody by the way there's a side on
my pizza just a little tin
of a little Olive Sage or something oh
oh it's oregano oregano oregano did they
just include that with no no yeah they
usually do pizza is actually did you try
that little chili oil I don't like it I
I know what it is I'm not a fan it's so
greasy it's just the piz as heavy as it
is
damn in New York this they they coat it
and the cover in that the pole
seems to be a bugged it's up at zero
zero votes divine intervention people in
the chat are saying broken pole it is
yeah divine intervention very bad po
this is actually a bad poll maybe the
worst that's probably the worst poll
we've ever made have we I know we
watched Hope I'm pretty sure and I think
we've watched sinful world but have we
seen betrayed and need answers I don't
know if betrayed
sounds we need to find the one where
David do reps on
it is that real or you no that was like
a I'm not mistaken there's an old one
where David RS on it really that's kind
of nice of him to do for Nick that's a
big ask
frankly oh he's tripping
cool and
care if it all comes falling
stay think to much of what I'm
say the
world I don't want to go to sleep now
cuz if Dem to my dream yeah these walls
are closing in can't
[Music]
beay all right
whatever that's not going anywhere
interesting okay big Nick he's still out
there Praise Jesus doing his thing we
love
[Applause]
Jesus
um oh you pound here it
is's channel it's yeah I guess David
doesn't rap in it he's just in it oh my
God but Jason's in it the whole Squad
there holy it's on Dom's Channel
you think he'll get claimed let's check
it yeah he turned into such a little
piece of
turned into always has been yeah
you're right I'm not even going to watch
it give him the satisfaction of buing
trying to claim
it
um Colleen's familiar thumbnails
H oh Olivia has a conspiracy theory that
she wants to put for
um I'll be honest when I saw this I did
get a little like oh no I felt I felt
you felt seen yes here if you pull it up
Colleen Ballinger did post a video for
her birthday yes and she has
never in my time on YouTube I've never
seen her do a thumbnail that looks like
that and that is the slide that I
included in the PowerPoint and if you
scroll down
you'll see the thumbnail that she put
for her birthday not
that that I've never seen something like
that it's always a still from the video
Sicilian message you think that Sicilian
message yeah so what's your
theory she she saw it and this is a this
is a subtle call out just like how it
was a subtle call out to her
ex-husband's new wife that she uploaded
on her birthday I mean it does look very
similar although I guess if you just
type party balloons I yeah I guess it is
but she has the confetti
too it is pretty similar I've never seen
Flags the flags is not common doing the
flags is all the elements are
there maybe her no I think she makes I
think she edits her
so I don't know I'm just saying if
Colleen was like I'm honestly I like
Olivia and I want to talk to her and
just figured out what what would you
do I would ask you if you want me to
wear a wire and then I would go in yeah
obviously she's like are you wearing a
wire and I'd
say yeah you would say yes yeah I would
yeah of course why would not Jackson has
a further
layer to the conspiracy she's 100%
watching and this is a publicity stunt
on her part she's manipulated you into
talking about
it
on she doesn't need to manipulate me to
talk about her well that I guess that's
kind of true you know what I mean but
we're advertising her new birthday video
all right let's go Colleen you're about
to give her r view I know I want to see
what her views are like cuz we playing
us like a ukulele
dude I'm curious for how rev viws uh
continue is this not the channel it is
crying about Taylor Swift and football
she's posted so many videos in the past
week I was looking earlier it's like
eight and8 days or something she's back
the views are not bad honestly still
pretty
good unexpected birthday surprise she
got
200,000 shocking update on Thanksgiving
that's what our video title is basically
shocking Thanksgiving
drama that's true though true that
thumbnail of her that says I've changed
that's kind of up no it is that's
clickbait it is yeah that is kind of
up I that's what I kind of
predicted last week I think she's going
to go harder and harder with like kind
of hinting to her apology and all that
and her drama in this case it didn't
work it has less views than the previous
ones it's getting there probably it's
probably going to get like 180 at least
yeah we'll see we'll keep an eye out mhm
just wait till the views really drop and
she's going to be in fully on the
that's interesting that's a good theory
yeah
um xqc got banned I like the slick back
dance um Roman Atwood blackface I don't
think we should watch
that
uh eel pit we have the eel
pit you
know
excc got banned but so what whatever
happened was it was it lifted was it
undone
stop oh yeah it's back this is on his
clip's channel stupid YouTube coward
sucks they
suck they should have left his dumbass
Channel Down H so dumb oh my God you're
right it's l gone H whatever people are
spamming in chat your YouTube channel
got oh yeah yeah yeah I think it's
because um like basically I think some
uh what the strikes were going to kick
in then I had like a counter claim and
then it just it didn't kick in in time
or something like that and it it's Auto
determination but it gets it comes back
up I mean I mean I'm sure you had that
before where you have like multiple
strikes and they're like all at some
time see the problem is that all the
strikes kicked in at the same time right
and that like since they didn't get
fought and cleared at the same time
right if one of them went through um cuz
I was only on two strikes I mean it's
it's a GG so I sure you're not scared
about like posting YouTube content and
with multiple strikes like one
could like destroy your Channel or
whatever you're just like it no
because the system is so pointless and
dumb he just dispute it and gets his
channel back
which the fact that he's even disputing
claims is crazy to me
I wish somebody would sue him what is
taking so long he's the uh the modern
day OJ they call him the juice man and
he's getting away with murder the juice
right
yeah true right like hey it's true
that's what I I move through life yeah
so it's like if you're not wrong I mean
you have anything to worry about unless
get deleted like mine did um which is
fine um bro why I'm not how do I get on
this side of the algorithm it's not what
happened I just want all the cheese
stick suggestions the entire
feed oh his yeah yeah good question what
is this
it's like Korean food Korean fries
fried
cheese this is what he watches I mean
not that
I not that my content is super elevator
or anything but he's running out of
content to steal so you got to dive deep
that's probably true to an
extent
um it's not that interesting of a story
since his band was lifted so there's
really not much to say about
it yeah hey do um I got an important
question hey what's up
Felix do do the tide uh pens AB will
they will they get will they get the oil
out wait oilz this is the oil from the
salad it dripped on my sweater wait Zach
why did you scream tide pin just like
a it's like it's a Zach ISM it's become
it's like an office meme you wouldn't
get it I hear every I'm the dawn of the
Tide pen okay Sam just used it right now
now Dan's asking me I wear a lot of
white t-shirts and I spilled coffee one
time and I had a panic attack so I
started screaming tide pin did it work
yeah it works how does it work it's
magic bro so show me does it take the
oil off but you got a scream Tide pen I
don't know if it'll work for just it's
just like
pure oil basically wet you stain your
shirt Dan is it it's just wet no oil
definitely kind of makes it darker
looking my grandma always says to put
salt on oil stains if that I don't know
the science behind it but no no maybe
absorbs it yeah if your grandma said it
we'll have to wait to see if it if it
dries clean here but thank you thank you
so much does anyone want this piece of
pizza because I I got to get it out of
my
periphery here people saying use Dawn
dish soap oh that'll take a bunch of
people okay I mean that makes sense it
cut straight through oil I've seen the
commercials so how long we've been going
here we're at 440 uh almost 3 and a half
320 oh we did a whole ass show we did a
whole ass show we barely touched the
dock dude the live show is
coming up fast man yes it is I can tell
you exactly how many days thanks to m
someone said eight shows away right
Dooms I have a Doomsday Clock here days
to show 20 20 days scary oh man and then
we're on break and then we're on break
for 3 weeks wow doing a three- week
break I guess we should start planning
for the live show soon then we got to
yeah come up with something to entertain
these people with yeah I was thinking of
just watching Korean Cheese videos for
like 3 hours live at the Dolby there's
no set it's just an empty giant stage
and one chair and just you that'd be
awesome and then next one time the Greek
that's right dude we should spend the
whole budget of to give food to everyone
there that'd be sick I don't just don't
know how I feel about doing the Greek
why why because I'm happy with the Dolby
size the Greek is so big there's no way
we sell those tickets we we're not you
will sell those tickets I promise every
time bro no I'm serious it's like 6,500
that's crazy it is very large he's a
humble King guys you were no I'm not
humble I'm you the one pushing for the
Greek you kept asking me about the Greek
you like pushing for I know but I'm I'm
losing confidence in it we secured the
date and now all of a sudden I didn't
put a deposit backpedaling and I'm
still thinking about it but oh it's so
embarrassing though if we sell if we
have like thousands of seats empty no
you're really underestimating the amount
of people that will buy
tickets who was it when did any of you
come with me to the Greek when we toured
it who was there I was there I was there
too cuz they were saying some other
comedy shows that that sold it out at
the Greek yeah really yeah I'm curious
what other show I'm trying to remember
who it was it was like other don't tell
me wait was it yeah they had one that
was one of them but they had other wait
wait wait don't tell me it's it's not
really a comedy show it's like a wait
wait don't tell me sold that out
yeah you know what that is it's like an
NPR yeah it's NPR game show comedy show
I know it's really
popular how many wait wait don't tell me
they had a few others too talk about
people that have the radio Cadence the
host of that show talks like this it's
such a boomer show
dude a comfort wait
wait let me talk this says the show
averages 6 million weekly listeners on
aamva podcast that's a lot PR big
monster that's pretty
big
okay and then there was the H3 podcast
[Applause]
baby um since we're uh kind of petering
out here and reaching the end of the
show tomorrow is
Tuesday your your computer is still
sitting right here here
broken uh and will be for at least a few
more days oh God yeah people were angry
about the phone people are not happy
with the quality of my product I think
that's so oh really people didn't
like I saw I mean maybe it's just CU
there was a lots of disgruntled I don't
know but I did see people being like
that get your together sucks it's
un it's skippable they're canceling
their membership it's not worth it I
don't know I want to make it better I
don't know what to do though whole point
uh you can come here and and do it from
here
easily the original point was that I can
do something that's relatively well it
would just be this week I mean I'll have
your computer back up and running soon
the parts actually coming tomorrow why
don't we do a PC repair stream
tomorrow we can be fixing it on the
stream it'd be good you should come here
anyways because then we can uh work on
the live show stuff we I we didn't do
that on Zoom yeah but then I don't know
I'm just trying to soften the blow
here I mean all right you do whatever
you want you're the one that was saying
the phone thing was no good yeah no I'll
have to think of something else the
phone thing I think people were people
saying it was
unwatchable uh well that was kind of the
joke but I really liked it I thought I
thought it was fun personally oh best
see you next Tuesday yet okay the other
I personally thought it was it was fun I
could see it being fun once but are you
going to do that again people are saying
eel pit that would be interesting do the
eel pit tomorrow oh interesting just
like a a whole episode dedicated to that
a me's only eel
pit but how I'd have to come here let's
talk about it off here people like the
PC repair
stream let's talk about people really
like that idea yeah I do like that idea
too it's not
bad all right listen
guys it's been Monday we all made it
it's almost 5:00 we all made
it how about those Mondays hey folks
they're the best aren't they they're the
worst uh but tomorrow for members stay
tuned something's going to happen I just
don't know
what um
however I do want to make a more
uh higher quality product on that day to
incentivize the members and to satisfy
them but I don't know what or how or
when that will ever
happen I don't have a computer right
now we can do yeah okay maybe I'll come
and we'll do the PC repair
stream that should be interesting
because I'm not quite
sure I hope you can fix it but I don't
know I'm feeling skeptical because of
how up it
is uh it is possible because basically
to uh just sum up for everybody Ethan uh
said his computer was working one day
and then the next day it wouldn't turn
on I thought to myself well bring it in
it's probably something simple maybe it
just need to receip something brought it
in plugged it all in and immediately saw
when I flipped on the power that all of
the lights on it are like glitching out
all over the place it like very
obviously something severe is wrong with
the motherboard and it won't even uh it
won't post it won't do like anything
like it's just it won't even uh get to
bios or say that there's something wrong
it's just completely dead so somehow you
fried your motherboard uh I don't know
how you managed to do that wasn't
me I wasn't even there must have
been so I got a new power supply and I
got a new motherboard thinking the power
supply may have been up and fried
it somehow I just I bought that computer
relatively recently and it was very
March 2022 so not long ago at all March
2022 yeah wait last year y well that's
almost two years isn't it it's a year
and a half I mean your computer should
last for longer than a year and a half I
agree I I like that computer I I I I
don't want to let seem like it was
running great up until when it didn't
there all right so we'll we'll uh we'll
do that then you know what I mean we're
going to get it
done and it's Monday and I hope you guys
had a great Thanksgiving
um and I hope you guys have a great
week we'll be back as scheduled for
Wednesday and Friday and members
tomorrow keep your eyes open cuz
something special is going to happen
tomorrow for
members that's
right you will get an exclusive sneak
peek at repair repairing the
PC never before seen
footage
exclusive all right guys have a great uh
great evening love you all thank you so
much see you
Wednesday shaking
fornite a shaking
fortnite a shaking
[Music]
fortnite